so good morning twitch and YouTube everybody
you change my notification hope I did it
fast enough
as long as I forget you have to change the
notification every time on Twitch account
how to make that cuz there's no thing to do
it drives me crazy
all right so what are we to do today today
I'm not going to rest until I have a Furrow
full virtual machine
hey that will
be created automatically from one command
using ansible so what is ansible
that's why I actually has an older
definition
so let's go let's go take a look at that
shall we
see here
let's see here what is ansible so he does
not know what a symbol is what
ansible is
this is a category of fictional devices and
Technology capable of near-instantaneous and
faster-than-light communication
that's actually not what it is it's the
second one it's an open source it automation
tool
that automates provisioning
I can figure a she management application
appointment orchestration and many other
Emanuel it processes
I like we're supposed to match between the
ansible users like system administrators can
use ansible automation to install software
on automatically configure everything so
answer will start a project then I got
consumed by Red Hat was doesn't make me
happy I'm not a redhead fan but it's still a
thing and it's used everywhere it's by far
the best type of tool for setting up
something and it's pretty clear I have never
used it but I've heard a lot about it a lot
of people that I really highly respect and
Industry that deal with virtual machines a
lot they swear my ansible some of them are
still forced to use things like chef and
puppet and you know even fabric back in the
day when the other is not as cool ways of
doing it and the number one reason an
ansible beats them all is because all it
needs is SSH access to the portal machine
I've heard people get ansible to make
virtual machines for them.
It's not within ansible scope it's not
designed to do that that's that's probably
not its main purpose that's what people use
terraform for or vagrants earlier I mean I'm
not a big fan of me videos about that
ignorance disastrously I've dated in bed and
buy butt and I may end up using paper in it
anyway but but if I could just start up the
goal here is I'm going to go ahead and
rewrite this so we can put this in our read
me this is a learning lab or learning that
for me means not that you're going to learn
from me and he's ever going to learn
together I'm going to do some color knee and
I'm going to write the challenge for myself
and then I'm going to leave the challenge
after I get home and documented so that
anybody else can go through and do the same
steps to learn about it the way I did and
maybe they can you do collect these learning
labs and eventually we will publish all
these learning labs in some organized way of
some for a registry and that's why by the
way that's why it's my directory here is
named lab Dash because anytime I want to
listen to you
I get home repos I can look at all my
learning Labs just by you know just by
listening everything that begins with with
lab and at will
sld where am I am I in the wrong place
so it's there they all are and you know
that's just that's just that's just my way
of my way of my way of taking care of so
there's a vagrant one actually put a big
thing of the beginning don't use vagrant
sucks you might still like it I don't sew a
free country
Teresa Sarah
best ways to save her kids it's a free
country I'll do what I want so yeah where
are we so it's right down the steps again so
the first thing I want to do
is
create a virtual machine somehow so you know
I'm going to put
I'm preferably using chemo if you are on
Linux
is it really doesn't matter how you get it
really doesn't matter
how you get a virtual machine only that you
can connect to it directly with SSH so
that's the first step actually already done
that step but that's the first step then the
next step is figure out ansible right so we
need to install and setup and some oil
which I've never done so we'll do that on
the local machine
and then we're going to be I think we're
going to be writing a recipe
wait we need to kind of like we need to kind
of like create a rough list
actually no let's just Dive Right In and
doing the recipes right so learn enough of
the ansible attack on the recipe I think it
is I don't even know I thought of something
I don't know anything and simple recipe I
just found a recipe that was chef chef was
hard as we think it's called My ansible
recipes I guess it is
it's like it somehow we and look how these
people have multiple recipes that called
mods
thank you for calling recipe so long because
of the old school right
oh my god do I have to do a yaml or can I do
yaml Media Center Michael notebook is going
to try to say so this is this is interesting
here's a person who saves their notebook
laptop
Play Books thank you thank you Cindy making
fun of me here
enough of the
all right enough syntax to create your first
ansible Playbook
I'm making these bold
I got that stew
some
I mean I kind of want to put here understand
why answer
answer the question why ansible
instead I'm just getting home
and she'll scrubs I think it's important I
tell everybody I already do that
it seems like as an as an operator
administrator a technologist kind of go
through stages right the first time you have
to make a new machine you like
when you're when you're young you're like
building your own machines and you're not
running around doing all kinds of crazy
amazing things and and your head cut off you
really don't know what you're doing but
you're just experimenting your learning
you're loving it and it's been tastic and
you just exclude learn Lennox and then you
some point in their you have to get shit
done
and so you can't destroy hop every week you
can't like I just wanted to or you can if
you still want to just drop me like I want
to just go help and I want to be able to get
my stuff on there really faster if you're
tired of doing it maybe you write it down in
the notebook all the steps
The Notebook all the steps that you did I
had actually used to do that I would write
it down in a book I did this verse in this
in this in this not everything could be
automated me some of us has to be done this
route so it has to be done you know
partitioning des and stuff like that you
can't you can't put that in the script you
can't you know that's a part of how the
system is set up and and it's hard to do
that stuff by the way you can you can maybe
write like redhead and 1 2 W both have ways
for you to to script the installer so you
can like hand off a script to the installer
and it would do all that stuff that that's
those are all solutions are really old and
your side the question but we'll hey I have
a multi-user system I just want to customize
my home directory I don't really care about
all this extra stuff on the DM and that used
to be true when you had a lot of multi was
our systems with these days he says nobody's
on a multi-user system everybody got their
own container or nobody would trust each
other on a multi-zone system very very very
rare I think even picoctf is change it's a
big to the Carnegie Mellon
pentesting competition site and they said
32,000 users on that site is rude you could
try to get what I'm trying to say is that
there's a lot of creative ways for you to
like create or configuration really quickly
and God knows we tried them all along the
path is somewhere in there you will end up
making a. Files directory and I just call
mine. Right that's what I've been giving
everybody you know given to give her. So
this is my this is my. Files refill that's
got all of my scripts is got me on my how
you install stuff you know I made a read me
for it I chose to make my. Files very
unperson alized so that people can just use
it if they wanted to that's really dangerous
to do that you should really read anybody's
you know stuff and then make your own you if
we can make your own
then I also have a repo is called private
which is on a USB stick that's attached and
that's got you know my passwords and tokens
and keep a sexy and all that stuff is on
there and I so I can bring up you I was
going to experiment with the DD script and I
blew my disco I like everybody has done at
least once and and and is a Sunday morning
and I was back up and running within 20 30
minutes I had to do was reinstall the
operating system and then installed get and
then I wanted to get into the gate pull and
I did our madman is telescript know to be
fair or set up a reminder set up script
right and this goes into all of his other
son directors run set up there and you know
it it is sells everything I have every time
I like it is it also kind of documents all
the stuff that I have on my sister so don't
file additionally I used to call this home
config because I didn't want him that I
change it to. Because the files is like the
common thing to consider 22
are you like that thank you Alfred people
people like using other people. Files has
been something we've been doing it since
we've been sharing. File since the dawn of
time you know if his before there was an
internet people would give you their of them
are see you there at back in his ex RC write
it actually see was how you define maybe
that's going back and you ain't nobody
starts with them with no extra could be
great we all do it we all step somebody
else's bash or see or you know somebody
else's functions or Scrubs N Stuff in and
being a Unix Linux person is essentially you
know means that you are
and I'm doing a lot of that you know you're
you're you're you're borrowing from other
people and that's what's so great about
being open source so they can get annoying
so I actually have an install directory here
I don't run this stuff but if I need it I
come over here and I look and see will how
is that thing installed so terraform has a
very different now these are like standard
apt up cake right so time time didn't start
till the creation of the internet
probably two and then this weekend I just
did this will be at scabs just plug it in
which actually fixes a bug that they Lennox
game people didn't know about it said oh it
just works I don't what's wrong with you and
like oh okay and I found out they were
totally wrong they had installed an old
version and I had to sell the new version
which didn't work that's all I wrote a
script to do it I need a video about that
you can go watch that video I put up with
that to you to email should be a vegetable
public today so this is I'm over viewing how
this stuff has been done to date but the
modern way to do this is to use ansible and
I don't know why I'm going to go into it but
I see you already saw people are using
ansible on the internet
go on the internet to create Playbook files
and I get it right that say Hey this is what
I'm going to do here is my notebook here's
my kids notebook and here's the media center
at so you can do all that configuration
which is so this was not just a setup script
it's everything it's like as I understand it
it it you know defines all of us if you
might want it also has a problem with it is
oh actually everything this will work
without having a virtual machine right so
you can do it
on anything you can access with us to Sage
that include your local system so if you
want to do this for a brand new fresh just
wrote and don't want it to be a virtual
machine you can also do that so it basically
it's like that the idea that of a. File
setup script on steroids because it can do
things that you normally would probably not
prefer to do in in a script right and you
might put everything in here is my my twitch
setup everything is it's it's not you know
insecure
this is actually pretty good actually be
installed it's not it's not optional so I
saw that all the time I've done this so many
times is a much better way to do this now by
the way this is an old script but but she up
so that's I think that's enough
so I want to look at Michael's notebook
so let's look at this one I think Michael
notebook might be his kids notebook computer
delimit research if the music is too loud or
anyting
there should be a way to turn the music off
so that would be not too loud
all right so so let's go let's go take a
look at this one I'm super excited about
this too because this is the kind of shit I
really love if anybody knows like when I'm
like him at any time that I have like free
time I'm at playing with your do that I am
messing with my config files or my life
scripts effort which because I enjoy it I
mean it and it's also educational so he'll
find me doing that a lot
so what does this have in it you know what I
think this this warrants just actually buy
it pulling down the whole thing
as well as bees I'm going to go map 7 you're
my new buddy
Map 7 I'm just going to pull up maps Evans
done we wrote this script the other day is a
great one to check us out clone repo it's
actually a function paste god dammit
always happens watch now what
clones it and puts me in the directory and
one command tell me you don't think that's
cool come on come on you do
navigate to change the state to CD into
another directory and stay there you have to
do it as a function you cannot do it as a
script prescription will refer back to the
state of their parent so let me show you
what I mean by that
I'm going to try that it's my day off so I'm
going to talk slowly in and I'm going to I'm
going to be long-winded here so here's
here's that that's super awesome little
function that's all you need now you do need
to install g h back to work and you do need
to have you might want to change it to be
however you do you do your stuff
so it also is is assuming it's from GitHub
you might want to try some different anyway
so
here we are here we go. Let's go look at
these files I'm just excited and also do I
need to get okay it says it's the yellow
file so we don't need any special ansible
them plug-in
web server for running Ruby on Rails with no
stress and no. Run ansible Playbook web
server. Llamo
that's B becomes to do if you were both
you can fix it
area code or just change the thing that says
get up to get lab or sorcerer whatever you
use
MLK Jr for the way and yes you know God
bless MLK Jr the serial adulterer who
brought us them civil rights movement and in
a major way
major way so
I always put all of our eye-cons are are
humans that's why I say that I don't say
that to disparage him at all actually makes
me respect him even more his wife knew all
the time what's the difference between a
volunteer form alright the short answer is
terraform is primarily for creating virtual
machines and setting them up with providers
there's thousands of providers that we were
going to go we're still going to consider
using terraform for this kind of thing but
ansible is for dealing with stuff that
already exists so configuring specifically
machines write it specifically ansible is
for configuration management and set up a
Beyond everything else that means it's
specialty is not creating course they can
apparently but it's not that special to you
was developed to keep configurations of
systems in sink and two just like if you
have a security if you have some
you need to change your profile and you've
deployed a bunch of the server servers you
want them to all be no clones of each other
which is kind of the case in the end
communities right with no it's a lot of
times it's the same Hardware you want to be
the same as I want all of these things they
have the same Library you do you change your
playbook and you run it against all of them
an update tomorrow reboots and does
everything is needed so so that so care for
him is for provisioning machines I'm Taking
Liberties here as I understand I'm also a
noob so I get it wrong please let me know so
I form is for standing up stuff and ansible
is for configuring that stuff I get that
database oh yeah I supposed to trust that
you was my favorite
collect postcards my favorite name is is
yellow file is also just as good a lot of
times for dinner or Jason files I'm a big
fan of that made Fatboy files as a database
as an organization for database people is
indeed a huge database engine
absolutely I would love to go and rest I
will then go to get a job I would learn R Us
to understand how your computer works
I think absolutely if that guy you're going
to hear me say it again
after I finish to see stuff if that going
through head for sea has made me want to
learn rust even more because now I can speak
very directly about how rust us up
differently than see so I think I personally
I think you should learn to see before rust
at least a minimal amount of seed might go
through the head for Seabrook I think
knowing that is really going to help you
appreciate the differences between rust and
see and be able to talk about them
articulately instead of just she playing the
stuff that everybody tells you
no rush espresso close Russ goes like this
assembly C
rust / C plus plus
and then probably go on top of that if you
were going to in terms of like level of
language that's that's how I would call it
paramiko
it's hard to learn things with their
documentation amazing that's what I've heard
and I think I think ansible is is worth
learning I didn't used to think that I kind
of do now
oh my God he's installing on my zeeshan
emacs with a theme even
why would you do that
it looks like there's already recipes for it
someplace
gather facts testing
well it's pretty amazing
I got a lot to learn obviously
I get a sense I'm going to be able to steal
other people's recipe of playbooks
use a programming language that works so far
I like it as well but I haven't been here
very long time I've already been streaming
for
what 23 minutes I just barely got done
explaining the situation
irascible result if youif you serve me to
simplify Lottery work
don't basic stuff that's that's kind of
where I'm headed with this
and are we got cell
yeah, task system, task background while
Mill
so it hasn't include thing it's it is it's a
language that only buddy freaking you know
to tell you differently learning and
learning as it was going to be learning a
language this is just a domain specific
language saying that they were generally
loses another language but has specific
syntax that's what this is is the animal
that has a specific context in which I can
before you go throwing her before more Helm
at it
that would be the exact opposite of what you
think I would use it for
but they didn't turn the server population
has red hat did all the things about big
companies like
please don't like that in you kidding me
bunch of angry Lenox boss people
nobody wants to put their their systems on
to that
I mean this this looks pretty reasonable
he has a a common thing let's go look a
common so common tasks
wow look at all this stuff I got all the
stuff
look at all this stuff God damn I'm going to
like this a lot I can already tell
you know what I'm going to do I'm thinking
I'm seriously the Caso spoiler alert I'm
seriously thinking about making ansible
setting of ansible and alternative for the
beginner boost to using a doctor workspace
container
so so when we do the Boost I want to give
people options and when they get when they
get Lennox I'm going to say look the
preferred way that I have for you to get
lennox's to install hyper-v hyper kid on a
Mac and run ansible on it run this
ansible-playbook the end
that's that's probably going to be my
preferred way the only problem with that is
you can't you can't snap it back so I don't
know I don't know I think I might not I'm
still an opinion about it I'm trying to
decide whether we want to introduce ansible
during the beginner booster we want an
interest during the infrastructure
engineering boost and I feel like the
infrastructure engineering boost is going to
be the way to do it
snap it back I want to I want to be able to
go back to a previous so when people are
really great thing about teaching learning
on it with the containers is that if you
screw something up you just create a new
container in your good to go he start doing
the steps in a container when you're a
beginner you actually want to repeat install
all the time you need to know all those
steps so that you understand what it takes
to get in the next machine running from the
command line and I think throwing an ansible
recipe with somebody unless they come into
the middle of the boots and they just want
to get things running and you know what to
do it that way so I will talk of that kind
of thing but yeah yeah I think I think
ansible does belonging and infrastructure
operations and I think because honestly at
the end of the terminal command line and how
to install software on Linux and that's a
hundred percent doable in dr. right so
install Docker desktop pull down a bunch of
image
you know proceed contact so I'm going to
talk to you in a bit I was at for a second I
was thinking hate you know if you want to
get my exact workstation image here it is
and I think I probably will do that I've
been using I've been using it darker when I
call dr. workspace image a lot and I think
I'm going to actually change that because
here's why I believe it or not the stuff I'm
doing right now actually applies to my job
because I'm going to get it back in a little
while and because they're refreshing my
Windows machine with Mac instead because
it's just better for everything that I do
then I Windows machine and a piece or two
doesn't work with my doctor just stopped but
there's a chance there's a chance that by
doing this with the ansible I can actually
get if I if I do the VM install I can use
this to get any work
any work laptop up and running ready for
work as fast as possible and then I don't
have to sit around in like save me work time
right so so that's what I'm looking for
I can continue to it works out for Justin
but I wanted to stop by because I saw this
time I got to kick it oh God
character cutter everything your keyboard
can do and more
type faster than physically possible
what the hell is this
I just knows
I mean this is the kind of thing I would go
for it cuz it's a keyboard thing
oh God
I fucking hate weird he was like that they
don't do anything for your original mix
simultaneously will automatically range in
3d motion detection
we're going to see innovation in this area
because keyboards or imperfect what the hell
that's crazy that's crazy
that's crazy
I think I think something like that's going
to become popular I really do
the problem with it is is that you're a
hundred percent bound to it from then on but
being bound to a specific keyboard is kind
of a modern phenomenon even with covid-19
testing each other's keyboards anymore I
don't like you go to a lab and usually
everybody the same key work that's why I
think his there's never been a time in
history where using your own keyboard
configuration layout to where I can whatever
is is actually okay
a Tavor shell script
well because it's a standard way to
configure it it would work on a cloud
deployment as well you can point it anything
that has a cessation able to it
no I'm not allowed to use Linux at work nope
nope I actually joked about quitting over it
and because that is how she doesn't work and
they told me he's putty or and get used to
it in my bucket I'm not doing
the very very in that sense they're kind of
the kind of old school it's a conservative
organization that wants to mostly they don't
want to give up the ability to spy on you
and their spyware only works on the on the
windows and Linux I mean Windows and Mac
so I saw a Mexican cheese okay
I'm going to get any laptop I haven't got it
yet they're going to give me a Mac
and most of that give me the nightmare says
more RAM I can't do my job on this they gave
me a really shity 15-inch still with a
broken like all the ports on the right side
of broken is refurbished at with 8 GB of RAM
to do a performance and they want me to
evaluate the applications of stuff
Spider-Man seems like we'll just do it from
the login server that doesn't even have
doctor on it and I'm like I can't do this
can't do this job with me. You've had sex
I just think what is a FreeBSD desktop
yeah it kind of is This Will maxar
the things I want to do is that I want to do
headless I want to see if I forget a 17-0
if you're going to see that would be an
awesome day stuff at work for video editing
the laptop I can just do anything they say
it's all yours already want to thank God for
you I mean most most companies are like that
but my company isn't like that also my
company says you should be using a system
close to the ones for the customers that
we're supporting so that you can help them
if they have a question
ya self
just so happens that the higher percentage
of Machinery people in our organization all
use max because he can't use Windows because
W because Debbie cell does not work with our
BPNC crazy shit ever I swear
and they still understand why and I'm like
okay fine mean I don't I don't wanna
complain too much I just want to work so
say why I should use this over shell script
my shortest answer Tuesday and some of her
shell script and we're going to find out
right now I'm doing that evaluation myself
so I can answer this my hypothesis on this
is that ansible can do things that I can't
do with the shell script under the hood I
think it is just a bunch of shell scripts
but I believe that that's
I believe that that's the main reason is
because it codifies the configuration into a
composable way you could definitely that was
shells cribs but it would be all it's my
phone yet
tell pythons actually turn Mica which is
which is the which was what fabric is 24 so
you can customize I think the I think the
shortest answer is composability and
I mean even if it doesn't really do anything
more than what I could have done with a show
script it doesn't and it consistent way that
is shared by millions of other people so I
would rather do that then customize my own
shell script that I have to maintain forever
and that might not be the same and it has my
own you know I already have my own
composition built into my set up scripts
right I doing it so early but if I can and
I'm already seeing what I really loved here
like if you happen to need job of God help
you if you do but if you did nothing in Java
UPS
you can you can share recipes you can share
play look so other people don't have nothing
in there that's weird
tasks
so if you can sell job here you go it's all
set up it's it's standardized and has a
description says I just think it's a kind is
a very organized way to do it and so I feel
like it's worth learning once your
infrastructure engineer I don't think you
need to learn this if you can be a developer
or just as a beginner boost kind of thing.
It even have Skype recipes in here they're
really cool thing is I can come in here and
steal somebody else's Playbook and boom I
just get it I don't have to do anything else
and and I don't have to make it fit into my
system this really is good and video
I mean this is this is a programming all of
his program using one place pgadmin get
hey I just think it's a really great as you
shall I do not want this guy's stuff nodens
e shell yard with Emax don't I but I think
this is the new generation. Filed in fact I
probably
I probably been migrating my dog files
somehow
into a Playbook
I don't even know what you would call him
you call him and tell recipes I guess
it's not recipes I would say maybe we say
Play Books
no we were just call ansible
and is that why people call it
I think I think having a. Files directory
and then having a playbooks directory make
sense in the modern times
executing tasks
and what what what what what do you guys
what do y'all think is a nice sudo standard
for
like if I
okay so I'm trying to decide whether I
should put I should put all of my should I
put my Play Books in my. Files directory or
should I put them in
I'll toss environment date data so I think I
don't think we should call it play well I
think we should call it ansible
so I'm trying to figure out
so I'm trying to figure out a standard way
to document all my ansible stuff and I think
I'm just going to make a note to call
ansible don't know what reason I wouldn't
want to do that is because if I have if I
have what's the base what's what's what's
ansible
a greater than Ian Diaz was Raising play but
yeah as well so I was afraid of this
I don't know if I call it ansible then I
won't be able to Fork the ansible project
even saying I won't be able to Fork it and
then work on it and do some missions of
stuff if you guys don't talk about sex one
of my biggest turn-ons as you get home you
can do this and get loud because you just
put it under a separate subdirectory
do not forget ansible why
why would I might want to Fork ansible if I
want to make a contribution that's what you
do
answers for Ryder integrated with ansible
that's what I understand we will but I don't
know
it's a play Mexican based on TV
I'm just a right now I just want answer one
question where should I
put my stuff I kind of feel like I should
put it under my down files
I might. I think I'm going to do that
because people if you want to find my set up
stuff I can be like oh where is that well
it's in my. Files but it's under ansible my
name is dollars everything already there so
that's kind of like the central play
somebody also I'm probably going to be
changing up like I already have installers
right I haven't saw her so a lot of my
installers ansible is the temperature of
your repo my setup ansible EnV playbooks
yeah
yeah plus I'm going to put that in your..
Files this is literally like everything that
I used to configure so I can set it and send
it to Subway so so let's do that make
directory ansible
and then inside of ansible I can make a
little thing here I'm just trying to get get
started here MD could say
my ansible
stuff
hanging foot warning here
a lot of this is duplicated in the installer
files for now until I can migrate it all
over so
what do you thoughts on that so my final
product here
so I think
the final product that I want here is
a place that I can go and just have it all
configured and I feel like
the average Joe can still go find an ansible
recipe and see the code inside of it right
I'll do that cuz it's going to be written in
Python is it not
and that fucking annoys me
I hate that I'm going to have to write it on
python tell you the truth but
so be it I mean the python is a better
language for this level of scope
so I think that's my fucking might go by
when you get over there I would rather mean
Canadian want technically because it just
calls it right this is it just call your
playbook and do its thing
yeah I think I pride okay so let's let's
actually do something here some is a python
yeah we do have bites on in here
what you are wanting to write in Python
stupid ever popped up sorry about that
because you know I have no control.
Python game
so that mean I mean I mean okay I'm getting
ahead of myself I'm really getting ahead of
myself so I need to slow down but but I'm
thinking ahead so I wrote this OBS insta
captions plugging in like 20 minutes
in like 20 minutes about an hour I have to
test it out and everything and I was able to
write this very quickly because it's so
dense and compact right
it's hard to read it wouldn't be a long-term
thing that I would want to keep and I have
no problem putting it over to python but I
really have no need to do that this is just
a personal installer script and I don't need
to make it like you know enterprise-worthy I
could do I could I could I could spend a
little bit more time making Enterprise
warning if somebody has a python thing they
could put it in there and put it into the
ansible they can add my my my file and they
could just add it to their setup
you can run fashion ansible okay so assuming
you have bash on the system then I would I
could you know throw these quick-and-dirty
Discovery things which the reason everyone
who's played the bass for the house because
I can interact with a draco from the command
line while I'm figuring out the script and
if you got the script out making all the way
I wanted to and put in it and I put in a
file will if I have to thin pork the whole
batch thing into python they did the testing
on that it's going to be a pain in the ass
is not going to be the same and because this
is a using configuration it's usually you
know dealing with phone directories and
dangerous stuff I don't want to have to
rewrite it after I've already tested the
patch version but if I can take that batch
code and knowing in advance how it's going
to land in the Playbook or the task whatever
the environment and in an ansible then I can
know that in advance and I can go ahead and
put it in there I haven't seen those are
cats have it done in y'all with ansible
modules we can run the bass commands using
as with built-in
I asked was just going to ask you the thing
right at the end of the day just connect you
and that's good that makes me feel really
good about that okay so let's let's let's
let's go for now I'm kind of trying to get
ahead of myself but I do want to I do kind
of want to start pouring my stuff over it's
just a remote as such I know that's what I'd
end of the day that's all it is right but it
but it's it's got a layer of of of
composable so so can I ask another question
up events in advance how how am I going to
share my code with others
see I would like to make it so that I have
it include file that has everything in it
including the bash rather than having to
make a play book into its own repo or
something like that or say they go to my dog
files and I can actually make a script that
shares that Playbook with them I can say you
know give give ansible or something that
might give ansible them and and then it
would it would send them the file that has
bash in Ventura at the whole bunch of stuff
in it and my goal is that I can have
composable single files that represent an
entire install of this particular thing and
that way I can share that part of the
installer without having any any
dependencies on other things so that's where
I'm I want to go with his I don't even know
if that's possible with ansible but you can
have a fight with everything in it or
appointment that has task and send you the
files yeah I think I'm going to put tasks in
to see your files is so that those tasks can
be shared with you
when do I get to guy says he wants to ask
you fishes or something you know what I mean
they can they can if they have answerable
they can just go add it to their own
Playbook and and boom they'll get it. Get it
right I got a question if
I mean I assume you can run individual tasks
without having to run all the combination of
all the tasks so like for example if you
just want to install I mean you can use it
as kind of a performance installer you know
I mean right now I would send you the script
and run it and back but if I can do the same
I send you the ansible file and you can just
run in and just kind of argued have both are
some people don't have an answer by low so
they use the Bosch if they do they use this
right but I don't want to maintain two files
I'm kind of getting ahead of myself but I I
I do a lot of this Edition pretty quickly
just drive to Seattle from the ansible
Escape Playbook
okay yep
yeah oh you talking about just just grab
that and that bit of yellow out of the
entire Playbook and then just have a single
Playboy for your entire for your time
workstation rather than breaking it all out
into its own files
that's interesting
I mean you can overdo it I think you know I
think it's fair to say that you can you can
overly Break Stuff up sometimes so yeah you
want to replace it out files that sounds
weird a certain number of my downfalls yes
my deposit still be there I just I want to
be able to recreate my workstation anywhere
like that that's the main reason the main
way to doing it letters better
yeah you can have that with everything
you cannot play with everything or taxes in
her file for inclusion you can do some more
tests using touch this text sounds like we
got a good start on the super excited
morning handsome. I think it's an essential
skill if you want to be an infrastructure
engineer today which I am next to pay to be
one and I'd have never learn ansible but I
learned a bunch of other great stuff so I'll
be able to answer the question why ansible
instead of get him and show strips so you
should be able to have that answer available
and then we need to create a virtual machine
somehow preferably he's in chemo if you're
on Lenox and what does it matter how are you
going to respond to see no way that you can
connect you directly and do you need me to
salsa ansible on the local machine not the
virtual machine for now
I know we need to learn a lesson execrate
refers ansible set up
okay so we already have a virtual machine
running I believe stage lists that we had a
virtual machine running
me and thing shut off is it deleted sister I
think
I destroyed him thing
I don't know if her a verse for a while so I
just I'm just going to run virtual manager
no virt-manager really quick just kill it
this way
doing I'm using chemo I did another video on
all of this so you can do it I'm going to
add a new one
so yeah
yeah we're going to need a new one so we
going to do
new virtual machine I look reason I suppose
I don't know if I have the one I want
I don't want to live server
how much is white and this is you don't want
that no no no I need I need to go clean
those out
yes I CD from a very distance place to that
spot
that's because I'm using a CD pass for that
why why is it still listed there I shouldn't
be there anymore I shouldn't be listed
anymore
that doesn't exist anymore
I understand all right so I need to get one
too
I'm going to need to download it onto the
old school way and this is something I could
have done with terraform but I'm just going
to go get it the old school way Hey look
it's me
I want to download I'm going to go get the
I don't get actually not let's go get
management workstation this is an
opportunity for me to test Linux Mint
Workstation
I like Smith's I want to make sure because I
want to get rid of Papalis eventually again
it stopped of us is going downhill fast
inflation instructions download
download cinnamon ye cinnamon is my favorite
oh I miss mint God is going to make me want
to get rid of my my OS completely
a Manitoba you can't accelerate to point one
GB installation guide
can I feel dirty using Papalis lately I've
given all this shit that they've been doing
lately by changing apt and and a whole Russ
desktop shit I think such a diverse and they
don't need to do that absolutely hate to do
that they should be spending our time making
their operating system actually work so in
some sense it does work but they but they
totally fucked up the user interface I'm
about to prove it they did a xmission this
is this is the company I called up in
in 1993 and said what do I need to learn 94
what do I need to learn that that will give
me the maximum opportunity get a job in the
other ones that told me to learn parole
that's it that's a new task and take forever
to Jeff how to download
it's not it's not really fast though let's
go back here
we can I download so I'm sorry but virtual
machine using Kimu
which installs work manager in a bunch of
other things and also allows who I found out
to emulate arm chips and a bunch of other
things so I'm super glad to have found you I
have been putting off loading Kimu for a
long time because I haven't really had a
need to to do things
I honestly I haven't had a need to do things
on
Linux virtual machine stuff on Linux if I
already had Lennox I am interested I didn't
have a really compelling need to do a lot of
stuff that way and now I do and so I'm
learning some of the stuff that I should
have learned a long time ago as an admin and
my problem is is it I'm about I'm about 60
40 software developer and to admin so I'll
talk later I have I have skills and both
sides of the fence and I'm not really deep
in either side which way she really hated
writing system software in like in a
low-level system software bug you know
enterprise system software because I can
integrate and write apps that take care of
operations doesn't like that kind of like
you know Super S sorry but but when it comes
to either deep-level like me and I don't
have haven't had that in the past so I'm
trying to up those skills little bit
I'm super excited by ansible even if it is a
python Tech then truthfully told this this
does solidly belong in the python scope in
my opinion they probably could have pulled
it off ago but given the volume of a stuff
that's already developing pythons makes good
sense to put this kind of stuff in Python
so cuz my phone's flexible enough yet you
know anyway move last
they're so now we moved it into a bunch of
images and we should be able to start up a
new VM using that
refresh where's refresh I said how to
refresh it
0 animation
just a minute alright They don't serve
automation that's too bad man
I know and I think that's I think that's
unfortunate I do honestly I think that's
I think that that is
I don't know if I want to say it cuz it's
kind of mean I I think
stopping at the bottom of a plant what
stop pool it's time for I keep forgetting
this is a
navigate me to the storage pool yeah storage
pools are a KVM thing that were very foreign
to me anything you put in here you can use
the volume very very to me a long time to
understand that because it's very specific
ATM
we talked about not detected it's a bun to
dummy
next weekend I'm pretty sure can I download
I don't remember
play Final Four
I was 20.03 why is it 2043
I don't know
I just downloaded the latest Papa was
released and I didn't look at it I mean
sorry I didn't
I didn't look at what version was I didn't
really say tell you the truth
I should look at it 20.3 oh that's mint 20.3
I wonder if it coincides
its latest member what version of a bunch of
us since we know I don't think it's actually
a bunch of space on Debian now right
did I read that they I rather they they they
they converted over to it to Debian
I read that they did every other day they
switched over to Davion
just released so far until 3:25 play 620
Coronavirus Anderson Silva highlights
virtualbox
what are transcription yoga sessions now
Denise what you demand
I am sure that I can just put generic there
to be fine
are in 2 m I sent you when you send me
Memphis are going to know that's a hold
there's a description line it says a 2014
1040 does that mean I have a present for you
I don't want to have to install and go look
for I need to know
some of these windows all time Linux Mint
Linux Mint just give you the least number of
surprises that's what I'm going for
I probably just but you know I have been
recommending Papa what's up until like last
month how's it going right
hey put it in the virtual machine if you
don't know what Linux you want install
virtualbox and install all the different
ones you want and distro hop your heart's
content before you blow out your system
do that then you can try out when do
managers and all that stuff that's what I'm
doing and you just know it'll be faster when
you get on your Hardware but don't don't
commit don't you into the Isle of Man I've
been using it for years but the last two
years of Asian pop
and then they change the pop desktop I'm
like fuck this it's so bad I kind of hate it
I hate it
and there's that whole shit by blowing up my
clinic lennis Tech tips
I download it when I want to know is what
version of Ubuntu is running or if they
switched over to Ghent is it Debbie and I
heard talk but they were going to drop
a bunch of entirely and I don't know and
then I heard other talk that they were going
to drop snap
and I don't know if they did it with you
mean it's a double and base install it's
possible that's it is it in Bristol
I'm pretty sure they're still built on a
bunch of but they got rid of snap that's
what I think they did
Linux Mint with my son a bunch of This Is
2020 though I just reported a bunch of
recordings distros makes you so numb as
everything on the expense of others take all
things out
cinnamon Edition
I know that snap is gone for sure it's 20
lbs but 21.4 or 20 then we go for a bun to
is referring to the 20.04 okay that's what
we needed that's what we need to we got that
answer so
I probably should write that down but
so let's do that we got aren't we going to
answer go back to her manager
3.04 which is l c s release
it's vocal which is 20.04 if I remember
right
you got theeven though I don't know what
that
it says its long-term release so that if its
20.3 minutes probably 2104 Lenox
I just wish it could have did you forward
I mean I I sometimes wonder about this
because I feel like that's unnecessarily you
know stealing a lot of memory but it's not
trying to do anything without four Giga Ram
is almost in specially graphically going to
be hard
and then mobile commercials
forward play 25 GB disk
I mean yeah I don't need a lot of this is
just I'm just automating some stuff
I would the Debian Edition yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay now I remember thank you
thank you thank you thank you yeah they did
come out the Debian Edition and I tried it
and it sucked it didn't have support for any
drivers or anything and I left
cvms tribal distro now I used I used to work
for 15 years I'm done with it
yeah my people like red hat in the morning
if you are and all that I don't
I don't but I can say I can say that after
having tried it for 15 fucking years and
written dozens of RPMs and dealt with red
hat I'm not I don't say that lightly
Regency directly in the terminal the chemo
because they don't know how I just know the
key move for days ago
I see internal Bubba blah black damn device
Levert images it's still fucked up because
of liver
yeah why is it doing it from sea cow there's
no cute cow
I've totally fucked up my chemo installation
while trying to get liver to repair form
I have I definitely have I have storage
their images I did
yeah we had this problem before I've had
this problem so many times
yeah
Idaho record yeah well I know that actually
I created a storage full under okay so
here's here's the thing that's so
frustrating about this this is totally new
to anybody's use virtualbox it's not the
same so when you go to do this you like a I
want to find it in my storage pool right I
sat so
if I'm using this I mean it'll grab it from
there but then it's like I don't know where
to sell it
electric eight custom storage
I guess I could put that in my own space
right
they only managed yeah okay I see
pretty images now I can do it in Iceland
with just
anyone so fast is the rectory
name let's do
oh God that's very nice
my son has it closest Mercury and Kayla's
change it to
I'm going to I'm going to make a new
directory in my Honda Rancher called pools
now that I understand keep him a little
better
full default
Why didn't it do you have a 4
whole default open
finish what when I said cinnamon
choose volume
no I don't want that is my custom storage
pool
just like how do I make an event volume 1924
North 4th
incontinent
she's cute seek our she she got to keep cows
got the thing back in stores
allocated Tire volume now and it's fine and
this is totally different virtualbox
so I'm glad I'm doing it
why would my color scheme this kind of match
beginning selection name Linux Mint
24/3
should we do net know we don't need that
because I'm going to be doing everything on
the same machine
it's name is not contain a space character
okay fine
vagrant sucks
I fucking hate vagrant after having spent a
full day with it it's a piece of shit
I never using it I can help it
it's absolute shit I don't know why this
didn't create this so I think I screwed up
my vert Mikey moo
so
no it was mine
Chris is streaming go watch Chris
I'm home Killing meccano Name Liberty
storage Auto read only true described could
not open will default permission denied how
the hell is permission denied it's in my own
home directory
my eyes I seriously I think I fucked up you
know what I'm just going to use virtualbox I
think I fucked up my chemo installation on
this machine
because we were messing around with live
bird so much to try to get to work with your
form
yep I'm almost positive that's what's up now
can I complain us license renewal process
exiting while connected to
alternate route to start a map could not
open Home default pull map
it's a person's Aura but do you see
it's like why does it have Arisen it's not
running as me right
no I'm not starting over with another user I
don't remember doing that no
we are messing with liver though so it's
very possible that I screwed it up
and I don't want to spend all fucking day
doing this like we did last time and this is
mrs. I'll probably just give you live
but I want to get it to work
so I kind of want to delete all of it and
reinstall it
does your user have like I think it was KVM
liver from which is that we did that
yeah we did this the groups
as you deliver right so a we we screwed
ourselves up by running in his room until I
had myself a liver and so I don't have liver
permissions
when I don't think cuz I don't think libert
has access to my directory you and I want to
see how I'm going to fix this
don't do this if you're me but it did it
why did it make it as root this is a problem
we had yet last time this is the bug this is
actually a bug we found a bug in KVM about
this very thing because it changes of
permissions
it writes it as route for some reason the
Daemon is running his route and so it
creates such that it can't even read as me
even though I'm the one in rennet we had
this person
we had this person the whole time to smoke
and get your phone really quickly it's a bug
and then we found two different bug listings
about this very thing
it's a known bug it doesn't change
permissions
it's totally fucked up it doesn't give me
confidence and keep him at all I'm going to
tell you
yeah it says because the licensing is what
was ready to recite something they are not
convinced it is not because of my initial
setup cuz I when I did the insulation
installer just rude and so and then it back
the whole thing out and now we still run for
some reason so best I can hope is to change
it after the fact
so I don't know shown
you going to follow me after that really
thank you
I don't know if that's going to help if
you're not yet using my KVM or system
I was trying to use using my KVM
we were trying and we had myself to the
group and everything but I think there's
some residual it's like still screwed up
yes I'm going to get there to watch it's
right here where I sit
SMUD plus rewrite
yeah it's totally fucked up yeah yeah it's
okay it just pisses me off because it should
not have been that complicated I did this
basic install for a virtual machine virtual
box is way better
yeah this is it right here so are you guys
one more time
app close Mac cancel
here's the liver is green virtualbox is
easier absolutely yeah
I mean I want to learn how to use Virtual
manager virtualbox I mean stuff and I want
to learn it
but it's just not working
it's not into quite frankly virtualbox is
going to work everywhere
yeah
error connecting to use our system I'm
connecting to my current machine
let's go all the way down to the chemo
that's what I wanted to do instead of using
a manager
I don't even know the difference between him
but there is a pain in the ass that mean
it's it's anything but usable I thought it
was something I could teach a beginner
absolutely nothing cute chemo is not for
beginners because it has a so many different
ideas about how to do stuff
began Windows additions episode 2 enable yes
absolutely that you don't work together
they both have time you can but you can have
one type 1 hypervisor and or 1 type 2 or
something you have to make sure we have the
right to refuse a bunch of them so they
fixed it eventually but yeah
Daiquiri virgin music about the absolutely
you do because virtualbox now he's the type
1 hypervisor it doesn't want to be so to be
on the same system you can only have one
it's actually one of the reasons that that
I do you spell to is a pain in the ass for
that reason to
yeah you have to uninstall the missile to
nabeel's U-verse about to meet at least used
to it maybe fix it
so this is doing everything is route and
it's fucked up so I'm not going to do it
I'm going to do it I M versus box that's the
average recommendation beginners and I'm
going to go and I don't want to fuck around
this anymore
yeah what is this
is it Saturday or sync email setup Genesis
ice age 64
I would rather use chemo for the command
line is that an option pay someone to
describe to me the relationship between
kemoo manager and KVM
so
so and as I understand it can use an
emulator that runs on top of KVM and you so
that you can give me that all kinds of
things including armed even though it's
running on x86 Hardware liver
Oliver is a card of high-level config and
control of chemo and others right yeah and
so they all use the birds cuz I understand
it
this okay so does Kimu use liver or deliver
Tuesday move cuz I haven't been able to
figure that relationship out never uses them
uses can move right game is the coronavirus
in Michigan that's the lowest level and use
that instead of saying these days he will
use his KVM and liver test is used to manage
Kimu right let them know I'm sorry is that
right so the manager over to Sagebrush and
stuff give me a music station keep me with
you and the colonel emulator and liver is
the standard library to build versation all
right so so hypothetically I should be able
to use the keyboard commands I'm using
Papa's right now
Asheville is chemo and I'm going to use
Linux Mint by discussing this cuz I'm
confused me from ya so so because I feel
like you like that I needed I didn't create
Kimu
Kimu KVM limbert
and birds
all of her stuff right
still got a game it's just Reeboks
thank you for saying that you have that's
all it is
confused by the relation
between the core components
of Linux virtualization
I think this is how they are related
KVM is the lowest level
and provides hey type 1 hypervisor
provides type 1 hypervisor support
to the Linux kernel and requires a reboot to
update When A change is made
KVM
effectively replaces Zen and older
hypervisor
and I actually have
send link as an I have another thing on this
one okay
it does sure does require reboot I beg to
differ I have a direct proof of that two
days ago
yeah when you install it now
I wish that were true we try that
and Anna I don't know we eat we tried we
tried to do that and we made some changes
and we had to reboot to get it to work
properly it was the only way so it's a good
box yet
parcel delivery chemo
I am people keep telling me I don't need to
and then every time
yeah I have all think eyes are nice that's
great for Lenox
yep so I don't know if it was because of
libert library or anything else but I'm
pretty sure it was a
rebooted give you theirs there are certain
things about them you can't change people
kept telling me to just restart the liver
Damon service and it was not enough
yeah liver Liberty we did at Liberty
restarts and in it sometimes we will fix
some things but not most things
so what so what is Lynn Verdi let's talk
about that so
limbert and Lindbergh
yeah and liver and Liberty
are that
is the library chat line for me
is the library
is the library in that uses KVM to get that
right
Liberty is a library that uses KVM it's the
thing that so tell me if I'm wrong here
the day is Damon yes I know other people
probably need to know that the DS for Damon
so chemo
is an application
that uses liver or does his liver use KVM
it's just Joseph
I don't know that's why I doubt I don't know
what's true what's true does Kimu use liver
and his liver Tuesday moo
is allowing to be a run near the Hardware
close in Cornelius got it hi
the kind of bad time but what no for me it's
not going to be for an hour at least I'm
sorry
Reverend Kenneth Fairley knighted KVM Santee
xxi
okay okay okay okay I didn't look it up
that provides emulation for
many machine architectures
is that right architech
checkers
including arm simulation on KVM
Ansari on x86
machines whenever May 64
so am I right that
uses
any one of several virtualization
methods
including
including KVM this is Suzanne with an
accident.
Is sex I which is Linda got sued for it
yeah Iyeah I know delivered that's another
good one
I provide that link
I wasn't planning on doing this in one of
your answer will but I need to get this
capture because this is driving me nuts
sorry about your salvation concept whoops
dammit
this artery delivers going out of control by
the Cuban KVM the most complimentary
there are different tools
acid on Terra Firma different tools is that
I started reading about virtualization
concept I haven't realized I think terraform
for provision forget standing up stuff and
answerable for configuring but I've been
told people to the opposite so we're just
going to look at it
did you survive a collision concert I've
been trouble by keeping KVM I can tell you
already that I like the ansible they do way
better than HCL from terraform so if I had
to pick between one and suppose probably
going to be winning with me I've been told
like it back here until they both have the
same give him when you get back in a
relationship and hypervisor KVM is just the
hypervisor that I know that part I know
then we can deliver liver is quite innocent
since that it doesn't confuse you it is
simply a virtualization management Library
that's it okay
so is a
all right
it does both KVM and Camus it consists of
three utilities
accessory utilities name with Avi the Damon
and come in like 20 of your Sage
alright sorry
I am going to kill myself over his wife
actually got to take him you can manage a
lot of papers together so when are we using
all these things and remember there is a
hypervisor accelerated aging accelerating
agent and Imagine Learning
all right that's good
I want to Key Bank ATM yeah that's what
you're saying well
medicine medicine what's yes
this more popular
are there different rules though I know I
don't group terraforming ansible together
yet but if I had to pick which configuration
recipe language to write in it would be mo
all day everyday I would know that over and
over over the revised rhcl I don't I don't
like a stale at all I didn't like writing it
when I was doing it and I'm I I'm not a fan
I know they're trying to do something better
the different tools of the right we we kept
saying this out of that if I got it wrong on
me no but my most people that I've talked to
most people will tell you that terraform is
for Bri up virtual machines and providers of
components has in volumes and stuff and
getting them ready and ansible is for
keeping them configured
terraform you know we're going to Forum
something new and ansible is for
communicating this way ansible means it
means you know it's a play on words but it
means you're keeping speed of light
configuration of communication keeping
things constantly the same so as I see it
and symbols for keeping things in sync
including the first time you
including the first time you can figure
something and terraform is for creating
something
which is implied by their names
I don't want to jeopardize our kind of a
concept think of him as a type 2 why it's
got a it's got its got Hardware support
is it going to wash in Linux connect to
service the current on the floor if you have
space for this type to you than you yeah
I thought Katie I thought Kevin was a type
one I thought it I thought it enable to type
I don't even know if I should die yeah okay
I did not know that
I thought it was a type one I thought it an
able to type one access
Kaiser Village again but still have him to
control have to measure yeah
didn't realize that okay nice
I didn't realize it was this that it's got
to be a fucking fast time to Ivan Biser then
normally when you hear type 2 you think
virtual machine like me like you know like
like versus a box of VMware and software
mode
it sounds like no right that's super
interesting to me
yeah
I think Thursday is at Liberty how long is
beyond Serenity run has its own user other
vacuum came out all the files that touches
now that is the owner
the way the way it's running right now
everything is route
my my liver Dee is running his route and it
does everything is rude and we uncovered two
specific bugs that have not been fixed
we speak up we uncovered two specific bugs
that have not been fixed in Liberty related
to that and I put them in the thing at least
we fought with that for 8 hours trying to
get terraform to her with a local liver
provider and it kept fucking ass over
because it kept changing it to route
permissions on the volume to even the matter
how much we we could have figured it out
it was here it was on Papa less and they
kept saying it was like yeah we were doing
this local system I don't know
I have no idea someone tell me I don't give
a shit I'm just telling you what it did and
you decide to hang out again I ran Levert
some people suggest it is because I
installed the software his route and Iran
Iran manager for the first time is roots and
they backed it out and try to hurry back it
in and then we couldn't get it fixed and we
didn't have a stable system we spent we we
burned about 8 hours trying to fix that shit
and then we found the bugs related to it
that no matter what you do it will still it
shows it actually shows it to the running to
to Reuters whatever it is and there's a
configuration and chemo at the keyboard to
to mess with it ha connect to be nearly as
fast as these days it was the worst dancers
make these perform really well nice / 11 is
the Colonel's processor model with you two
crazies and processes and ice
give you a massage when I want to lose you
as a girlfriend smile with chemo so you tell
me KVM actually calls chemo emulates a lot
of devices Anyway season and I'm usually
more companies yeah, Lise if you have a
really good reason to just have fun give me
a place to rehearse where I said 400-yard
stream live anywhere with you
let me talk to you since I want a visor
and I understand that that let the little
box uses it is a type of these days if you
have it if it detects it'll use it but I
don't know
Team Umizoomi space talk to the KVM in the
colonel yeah okay
and talks to do the colonel
through KVM yeah
so yeah you're actually limited even know
what your C
and if we supposed to have sex when you're
extremely limited yes interesting to give me
images of space toxic ATM in the colonel IQ
is about to pull for emulated networking
devices just cuz I see Sarah I know your
network devices yes and it emulates arm to
which is really amazing they gave him is
responsible for safe CPU
modes
Patriots on TV is actually also type to
really
sza type 1
I did not know that I did not know that that
I got that wrong in I swear to God I read it
a different way but again my memory is
really bad so
I had to go talk to box
so so so so so Douglas L2 is level type too
interesting to type 2
interesting Okay so
a cumulus application in user-specified
simulation machine architectures including
arm simulation on x86
other thing is that it's not too bad enough
you went to the wrong blog post should be
viewing it from our sexual standpoint and
we're very Colonel's usual ants live at the
separation used to make a grooming
interesting
interesting that's that's super interesting
to me wrong that's why I want to write I
really don't care I just I wanted to work
quickly excetera and there's a lot of you
know stuff that you just want to work by 2
a.m.
but yeah I took email Kim calls into the KVM
and liver disease vs. these are all together
and they give you the virtualization that
you need for anything and have a great thing
I thought was interesting is that in order
to to had to restart Liberty but I had to
change at Sachi move stuff
mother of Jesus run as yes it is mine I
tried to tell everybody why is it when your
urine has to run his route so that the bug
about it if you want to know there's a
there's a bug that says that Liberty is
showing the new volumes and into roof and
that is the reason for the conflict has
ulcers in the provider doesn't work we
thought it was the provided was doing it
wrong I love her key provider in fact when I
do terraform again I'm not going to use the
local Liberty provide her because that's
less support I'm actually going to say it's
just a provider and make a VM when the
reason I'm doing this I want to make I want
to make a terraform client VM and I'm going
to use my host OS as a pseudo server and
then I'll connected to an inter Arma. If I
need to but I'm going to try out to do this
all with ansible by itself and then out the
fuck with all that stuff then I'll just get
another server later with molten core and
I'll just use terraform as God intended and
and Stan
I'm up and then use the ansible to take a
figure that's that's my my goal anyway so
that would be most consistent with how you
would you would work with it in the cloud
from what people who know better than me or
telling me anyway so
I think this is a pretty good breakdown of
the differences
alright so let's go ahead and say that I
just needed to get that saved
you my favorite types of a use case as an
essential has its own schedule her for a
chelation drivers about the current I don't
want to use end because I've heard people
don't use it anymore I read that whole
article and from Amazon about the migration
of Zen to the KVM
yeah I wrote about that so
Amazon drops in
I didn't buy the future released versus
everybody's concern Elsa 2019 Amazon Nitro
on KVM and drops and Kimmy I'm required to
her support for virtualization and see this
is what I don't understand they said that
they wanted a type 1 hypervisor and a KVM
provided in your telling me something
completely different
so you know I feel I feel like I got that
got that wrong
I-77 is type 1 or type 2 and this is if you
don't perform instead of sending wrong if
you can before we had rather a risk and
Emily's and keep him for everything as a
method for meeting up with Hardware like
everything you're telling me is completely
against what I read in the Amazon Plus most
makes me want to find the Amazon post
Amazon drops zen zen for KVM I I need to
find this
big truck games that are source of
information in code camp
I would not be the first time I've been
fucked over by that's place I swear to God
watch it be because of this shity article
he's into it because they require really
thin idioms something Amazon using no they
don't directly, Colonel function with any
special crazy and Paige ensuring that could
have some type of calls injection faults are
the type to if it needs a special mechanism
is Stefan interesting
is it for a tattoo for your use case
what's he doing this why I'm confused. Okay
so tell us what it is easy to high end
stores time is strong suggestion that Amazon
cloud computing giant has begun to shift
here's another one
the register is a reliable source they've
been pretty rare that they were the ones
that broke the the Snowden story and a bunch
of other think it's hypervisor I want to
read that instead
I was in in with Corky and technology for a
see if I missed this feature VMAs 2017
mine's I just change it you want me to say
here you go
and see is everything secure in there there
isn't right
did you remember I don't remember if I have
tokens in there or not I don't think I do
give me a sec while I look up
free Camp courses are shit
York's absolute shit I would not waste one
second over there there JavaScript steps a
little bit better but they're absolute shit
I seriously I would I would not do it I
actually have tested 40 people who went
through their web certified program not a
single one can make a web page after it and
then I I cannot tell you how much I disagree
with their entire approach their approaches
get the carrot get the piece of paper move
on there's no active recall there's no
there's no practice is no repetition and
then people ask him questions online on
their Twitter feed and Quincy says to him
well obviously it's not enough to get a job
you have to do another 2,000 hours of work
why don't you start there and throw them out
the fucking window their content is so bad
it actually teaches you stuff incorrectly in
multiple places I cannot overstate my
disagreement with people doing freecodecamp
I agree it's exactly what you would expect
from a former Middle School
principal who goes to a boot camp to change
careers and decides he's going to start is
going to change the world by kraddy
freecodecamp but that's his first project
without actually asking anyone with actual
knowledge of the topic to do it and after
the fact has been like playing catch-up ever
since then I have no love for what they're
doing I wonder what he's doing I think it's
a great it's a noble cause of the lab people
got jobs for Pico camp but I absolutely
despise that is a platform there aren't the
Odin project a little bit better learn with
me on is actually saying he's got some good
stuff but if you're going to do web
development I got no information if you did
what was best for you for the loan is to
make your own program for Learning and learn
how to learn and set up your own system for
learning
stop depending on you to me or some quarters
or some book and make your own program
go find people who are actually employed
doing this job and ask them what they think
you should learn
no se learn this and learn that so then you
go do your internet research
you go do your internet research and you
create your own curriculum with starting
with a list of the things that you need to
learn now we're trying to help you with
something called open credentials so that
you can see what you need to learn I'm not
mad at you by the way I just I'm super
frustrated because code academy of
freecodecamp.org to some extent they teach
you shit that's wrong it's not even based on
any you know what I did I can't drive
anymore they gamify the shit out of it
people come out of it with a certificate
they think they know something in fact or
even more dangerous because now they're
injected with unearned confidence and then
go try to get a job but I do try to do
something they don't have any portfolio
everything smells like a tutorial those are
Leon's worth the end and they have nothing
to prove it they would have been better
served by asking a professional finding an
actual professional and asking him say can
you spend 10 minutes telling me what do you
think what it is I need to learn to say I
need you to learn X and Y and Z and then you
setup your own project and you go learn
those
can you put that stuff in privately and
you're getting a repo and you manage your
own learning and now guess what you've got
the skills necessary to continue instead of
being dependent on freecodecamp forever or
free code whatever the fuck it is I'm sorry
I just my opinion on that has gotten a
little bit more grumpy over the over the
years because I keep getting asked about it
and if you know that then you can go into
and you can use it as a resource okay but
yeah
you don't need to prove you got mentored by
a professional
your proof is what you can show its what you
have delivered
all right I'm done
Dynamic ownership I don't think there's
anything in here that so
max to change one variable in this sand and
I haven't rebooted since then
my I don't have anything in here this is
just the standard ones so
Etsy
and you can tell me to take a hike your then
charge of your own learning if you like it
if you can respond to me to get a job that
you would do something good about if we go
again freecodecamp and the Odin project have
fantastic communities if anybody getting a
job is because of the community it's not
because of the material
Lynx Academy
is that what you're learning that there's
some place to get free stuff in and have the
best way to learn is to just experiment with
things my hands now and that's the way
you're going to be learning for the rest of
your life as a technology professionals to
might as well get used to it and it makes
you uncomfortable sitting up your own
learning labs in your own learning
environments and writing down their own
steps in your own goals about what you need
to learn and then just going out and doing
the research to do that that makes you
uncomfortable get the fuck out of Technology
because that's what it is that's what the
job is as Liam says it's a lifestyle it's a
lifestyle you commit forever to managing
your own learning not to asking people where
you should go to learn the next thing you
need to know how to do that yourself as the
first thing you need to learn
here's some covid-19 South KB I'm in Lenox
included including the external interface
has one thing at a time I'm getting kind of
distracted that's all right
UPS so here's my chemo chemo file
why is it doing that
at City Live Birds
chemo chemo isn't in there
can never type this what do you mean
permission denied
cannot type today give me hear Mozzy
this is my don't get upset just get busy
mascot
there's my
learn how to be like yes absolutely
are some code nice out give you a goddamn
open link in a new tab
yeah I want to I want to grab all this so
you guys are being very helpful today I need
I need to have
I need to have this stuff in in my Latin
learning
Alright set edit I appreciate the references
are just going to be able to do fast
pissed
all right what is this now
succezz so junky says
nice I gave him his Lenox includes use his
lunch Colonel interface is here but Zen uses
its own
rental wedding function on your different
way interesting
God damn this is great information copy link
address I got to put this out there for
everybody else
documents
the other one and
hey since escape this is an right I said a
document
so if you guys want to look up this stuff
and putting it in. So you can go read it
instead of getting lost
that comparing TVM and Zen code in the
kernel source can be
a way to understand the difference
let's put KVM xen vertebrate
I'm going to put in the dock so I don't get
lost I want to say when I'm bored how can I
I know we're going to try that trying to
keep up with all the great comments here
but I was going to buy the Steeler things to
try to figure out what's on the first
absolutely knowing what to learn is the
first step and I I did a boost for that
reason
and I tried to create the the ocms
standard as a way to to help provide a list
of what you need to learn that's the very
first thing you need to figure out the best
way to do that is to is to ask people like
like chunky still chunky still knows the
questions to ask about KVM and then I have
to battle is getting people who fucking know
what they're talking about to tell you where
to go you don't have to tell them teach me
everything you have to say tell me what I
need to learn where to go to look for the
stuff because I am willing to do the
research I just don't know what to look for
and that's where a mentor is absolutely
indispensable and educator who try to give
you a theory that's three levels removed
from some other book and some other place is
never going to get you the right information
unless it's about an academic topic like
Quantum Computing find somebody who actually
does this shit somebody who commits to the
colonel and ask him the difference between
Zen and KVM and Jose basically it's this and
here's the line of code you can go check on
to give it to any changes it those are the
people that are going to give you
true learning they gave you the best
possible learning and build yourself a
professional Personal Learning Community
surrounded by these people even if you're
just a fanboy and you're following them all
the time and you got a list of these people
that's how you should learn you don't go
follow some X principles idea of what
freecodecamp should be so they everybody can
learn it you go to the top of the profession
to go to the Masters Class the mentors to
get as high as you can and you ask them what
you should learn and then you don't bother
him with the rest
that's the way it didn't truly learn that's
the way we've been learning from greybeards
I thought was a sexist term but that's the
way we've been doing it and eunuchs world
since the dawn of time there's never been a
class on Unix anywhere
it's always been taught it's always been
mentoring and apprenticeship I do reach I do
reach at
but I don't necessarily read
which one you talking about the Discord chat
I'm doing something else right now at the
box I don't know you're asking questions on
related but my board is old how can I set up
a server on a bun to
you just download a bunch of Anna saw it
are USB stick you need to burn a USB stick
that's how
Okay so
I used to know house to pay PSI do I do
sometimes it's easier I didn't use enough
space here though
I just announced the pace from I use the
mouse because I grabbed it I grab the URL
from from twitch
so that is the most efficient way to do that
like I could have twitch up in another
window and go copy the coffee and the
chaplain WeChat and everything I have done
you know what I actually had a command it
was called last it was called last URL and
it would do that it would like to follow the
chat but it's but it's gotten a WeChat fi
phone lags it's not a fit after waiting 10
minutes for 5 minutes for it to show up once
I get it bought once I get it bought for me
to post any stuff from the chat I can just
post I can just do bang bang last and it
will grab the last URL from the chat yeah
that's coming problem with that is is it
WeChat is too slow it doesn't it doesn't
commit to the 50 fast enough and so I can't
grab the URLs fast enough that the logs I
mean it it it buffers the logs only writes
them every few seconds and it sits too long
it's not as affected by the time I want it's
always pulled out the screen
a couple of good courses on Unix nice not
aware of any likes wants these two extension
really going to jail that's nice teach me a
c
learning Linux command line is another free
good book I mean these are all is lots of
the resources right there
let me see if I have anything on this
I had lots of Lenox stuff so it can be hard
to isolate
is that create Onyx learning resources
but young Annex
hey look paste from the command line non
command line
schedules and routes as nice as good to you
as if I really want to get into I know I
want to get back to ansible here but all I
wanted to do is get a virtual machine that
works at the end of the day and for
beginners and the clear answer here is don't
use chemo and leave it and liver don't just
don't use it I hate to say that but that's
that's that's the facts of the matter it's
it's too I don't know I feel like it's I
don't feel like it's baked I haven't had to
finish reading this because I think I got it
wrong again
New York New York hypervisor unveiled is
virtually brand-new ez2ac 5 news has long
championed sin is in Project can do one or
two
why don't you see those databases you if you
think going forward we use everybody to
Paradise Tonight
what's that of course nice
is that at last
thank you for that I'm going to keep those
up and put him in my set you guys know about
me is that right so if you want to go follow
that you can just follow the GitHub repo and
it will notify you any time I updated there
it is it's got all my stuff that's as I
video transcription using CC as well so if
you want to search you can do that
I'm I just had at this week super happy
about that
I have closed captioning enabled as a two
days ago, Castleton
you can go to see it so if it's that is that
query
those two things to give you plenty of
information if you want to answer that
question because it'll be as long as
champions in
Cumming 400 series this hypervisor sounds a
lot like a dumb ass is giving Zen the flick
you have a long way toward explaining why I
do this is the last of the big clouds to run
Intel's new Skylake Xeon CPUs because it has
also revealed the new C5 instances and tell
us both say
that some stuff until 7 Customs yes for a
while
give me to give me a surprise in batavia's
does whatever is needed to tune its Cloud
for auto performance that means building a
hypervisor and making sure it's okay they
just said building a hypervisor
so that would mean type 2
and making sure it hooks into Customs eons
to some beer whenever it feels in three
weeks is this I believe I got it wrong and
that summary whatever evils in the next 3
weeks into this is now saying that C5
instances in the visor are about facet
referred as an advantage being a Prius past
the network
here's the day Joe said to send it back
didn't have a razor for Amazon ec2
introduced the launch of C-5 mysticism is a
component that normally provide CPR
memorization okay
is built on Courtland KVM technology but
does not include Jennifer suffering system
components
it isn't only modify give him extensively
and because they don't distribute anyone its
private for them it was probably easier for
the to do so a KVM that it was within its a
hurry up yeah I think I think they made
their own type 2 hypervisor I think that's
the way to say it right
I think I think that's that's what I'm
trying to say here
adopts Homebrew KVM yeah homework avms new
hypervisor so I have some errors in this
I sell for their own Homebrew KVM so
did you give him requires Hardware support
for virtualization that's not true
that's not that's not true I swear to God I
read that though
I got it wrong based on everything that you
just said
now I don't think people KVM I don't care
it's my day off don't give me shit is it
possible to run Ubuntu on a Chromebook and
do the thing I should probably change my
stop and go seek and it's a pain in the ass
know you can try and it'll pay your
Chromebook is a Chromebooks really only have
to take it apart and take a screw out of it
otherwise I won't let you change the OS no
shit we actually tried it depends on how old
your Chromebook is the later, books they
have full support for Lennox installs they
made a big deal about in the news make sure
you do that research and look at your exact.
Is my tab a comparison have you seems to
have stripped down all external Dennis was
breaking point of seizures run in for him so
he takes it more more of it more of a type
two type want to see if I can remember
mostly Colonel functionality there isn't
really a part of the Osa more it is running
this case interesting I just moved from
Tenny KVM because they are I aren't you
instance type Nitro yeah I can project for
the service he didn't fire cracker right
yeah and firecrackers the whole rust thing
didn't talk about so
I don't know how you're going to do research
on which one of work these days if
if you need any relation you're doing
something wrong I don't care if I don't know
what the fuck that means Rob
I might have got that wrong I got to find
the source I should this weather-related
section is so important to keep track of
your sources as to me I'd rather never risk
it Wednesday KVM for
I only using KVM for everything as a method
of eating out my old Harbor from the new
which is so serious I don't even think that
that is relevant
I don't as a hey thanks Tamara
okay if they don't have Hardware support
I really didn't know this is not homework
avmc hypervisor
Adventures of Peace key. The maze if you ski
I can see it's working and KVM to most
people if they know exactly where they needs
in Veracruz in to do the research and look
for Dakota yeah
we only use KVM it might not work on my solo
Mesa if they don't have time for this is why
I ran into this morning about proxmox I do
remember that so
where where are we 5
I am going to finish this article and where
you go back to where we were I might have to
stand up and take a break cuz I'm down to
the big old Rabbit Hole like email or Bosch
it it would even work without our support
but every Garcia because chemo does
emulation right I feel like I'm getting
honestly I have never really had my head
around and Lenox virtualization I never have
and I Lenox personalization is at the core
of cloud so if you really truly want to be a
kick-ass 10x do you know infrastructure
engineer you really should understand
virtualization like at the court you should
understand how the colonel is organized into
were so close everything and I don't and
that's why I'm getting into this I did I
also want to just can't picture my local VM
but it's a good opportunity to look at this
Jack 64 news station
is it recommend KVM to most people assume
that you don't really understand it because
because of the way it is percentage of
people is that black box is a clear division
between them when they really have to do my
thing yeah yeah hypervisor what even is a
hypervisor right I mean is it there
is hypervisor firmware in
is it I mean what what the literally is a
hybrid by type 1 hypervisor I assume it's
firmware on the chip
right I mean it would have to be into
something like how can it it's like a GPU
where it's like an instruction sets it's
been burned into a chip
and I that's what I'm kind of curious
network storage done elsewhere and did you
ever measure provides consistent performance
increase computer memory
install new exercise for losing u e j e c t
i v Riser but in the near-term so many
successful use and depending on the
requirements of my phone is running on the
new easy to type of hypervisor PCI devices
does not work that regulation well yeah
check the FAQ a review CPU is a single
thread on a on a physical CVS thing
yeah I think we're done with this one
Azure content that's very nice expert she
welcomed good to see you it's really not me
it's people like Chomsky setting me straight
I'm just I'm just a fool in front of the
camera
it's true it's true I'm Just a Fool in front
of the camera and gets schooled by other
people actually know and I guess that makes
for good entertainment
so yeah anyway yeah I got to make sure this
is updated
all right we're getting back to the topic I
promise
I just need a break though I've been going
pretty hot and heavy on this again the topic
is using ansible to setup your workstation
as opposed to shell script to buy to do that
and I'm going to
put up the read me of the stuff at work
where we anticipate working on while I take
a break so I shall be back
I should be back in about 8 minutes here and
I'm going to make some food so I'll be back
in 9 minutes
so see you in a bitsee you in a bit
whoops I didn't work
batter fish men are fish.
When I resize
back when SA
if k for a bit of that
somebody seems they spend a lot of things
last stream already terraformed and smells
like yeah I do I do the whole thing the
whole gamut cuz I can't get enough I'll be
back in a bit
alright I'll see this I'm done eating
let's do it let's do it
I haven't pressed coffee that's a little bit
of lunch with my wife
kissing a lawyer do Maya
New York City Housing
like what
I'm Emma streaming leopard Shima
show me a review on a Vice Lord now about
you
Frosty Drew study at the Roost music
Anthony Russo music wow
IBM has 12 has 12 hole viewers using like
shity default team Oaks
on Windows machine
I like his beard though may I kick ass beer
in there I'm out of here
new melodious Mala Jets melodious music
the London agent
did you know ansible has cows a support that
things are in a meeting until he was half a
cow's starts popping up all nice musica
I'm going to let you know. Cautious
yeah just pulled a stupid him out how about
how about you we got to eat you
yeah it's a funny Mario
my closed captioning are freaking the fuck
out right now they have no idea what I just
said okay
make a plug there is now full closed
captioning support Sonora TX Rob thanks for
the OBS plug-in if you'd like to know more
there's a YouTube videos you can watch how
to set up for yourself does not work with
streamelements by the way which is kind of
interesting because most of us which uses
streamelements for Tobias and in that
specific case they're fact because they
can't add it was closed captioning but we
can because we use Linux
so there aren't back to what we were doing
weight is a white ansible I could have named
that that made the closed captioning rat
with a compiler
yeah me too I like that a lot and he's a
good job to buy me
IR doesn't work under $0.04 no it does not
but in reality it doesn't work 100% but it's
better than nothing particularly if you
can't turn on sound and if I make sure to be
Chloe and to enunciate
I said I said Chloe insteadChloe instead of
slowly
I am a horrible speaker II munch on words
all the time
all right
at what are we doing out here we go
kravers machine somehow I don't give a fuk I
can't create a virtual machine used to live
because his doesn't work how can I create a
virtual machine using chemo and stead of
liver
I might try that
I am going to try that
touch build I do this all the time
create a ritual machine he's in chemo
directly
yeah he must have been an extensive command
line I'm game
I can't use the bird cuz Leppard sucks Brit
manager fails me constantly
Arabian unless you had they gave him driver
are you saying that if I didn't use liver
it's going to use is going to use the KVM
directly instead of chemo
hi Liza seem bad to me
well I don't know I have no nothing to go on
so how do I create
all right yeah are you talking to me
my wife's talking to me
yeah this is it this is definitely a toy
appointment
keep moving all right. Are you kidding me
that's it I didn't look right
bad Mateo as soon as this one say
so I meant your credit is so you have to
install chemo KVM
human create is it shame on caregiver
to be able to escape him directly yeah it's
what I want to do I want to bypass liver cuz
it's all fucked up right now
always return appointment
I do have a Home Server yeah but right now
I'm doing on this system this machine
ffq Cal just finished ucal 5u
is a great of the cicada file I said so I
can write and solve a system in the system
as you want my sandwich woo
August 6th this sucks I just I'm going to
follow this my father's tutorial
hello my dear
I already have coffee I don't have coffee
and tea that was nice of you
not in it not right now anyway what's up
I think you like my
I adjust switches I don't have any say I
didn't take it it just randomizes it I'm
saying
it is it is it's very day that I noticed
they do have a good I like the fireplace
kind of cool
so what we got here
at the moment got to be we went down the
rabbit hole with KVM
yep went down as you drive home with kabian
and chemo and liver and how they all relate
to one another
am I didn't listen to all to manage we have
to cross Lenox me to do my God that would be
so cool yeah
is it back to give me directions to
Thunderbird I'm not using a nope not so
I've been stalking and KVM and we have that
already
I'm pretty sure we had this already yep
did you try the arch open in new tab let's
take a look
oh God good old Arch
Kimu is a thing
where can I go to my thing go god dammit
all this great stuff that I got a document
what is chemo chemo variation goddamn ass is
long I don't know if I want to I thought I
already did this already did this one week
please night but I see you studied Asic
Miner and you smell
I'll have to go open those
2 2 2 2 2 2 2
anime
good old Arch
yeah I don't know man this is supposed to be
the ansible I am seriously tempted to just
use live VM virtualbox on here because I
haven't already here and come back to this
later so I can get some some understanding
of it we're like pushing time here here for
support and lvm graph
I kind of want to do this but you know what
I'm going to make a Command Decision and
we're going to
we're going to we're going to not do that
I'm going to keep my sea life nice thank you
for that
I just want a mufuckin virtual machine
that's it
but I'm really trying hard to just keep
feeding to do this Linux way I really am I'm
trying hard to not did not sell out and you
know use these Oracle software
how many tables is already went to Clyde
images of skill new hires yes I want to go
to the next ktvm to make running a bunch of
them easier to plant images
SMS reminder platforms yes yes dinner was
released yes minimal images when we went to
images yes they got rid of this apartment
anymore I heard like up someone's got to
stop supporting minimal they have the
Cardinals been up many many more
so Elsa got the daily
give me some what to do with the IMG file
which is raw which is a chemo cute cow image
see there it is right there how long did it
take us to get an answer yesterday
how long did it take us to get to the answer
yesterday
because the file said it was a cuckoo maran
to me like why is it named Donna mg and
confusing the shit everybody because it's
not raw
I mean that was a fucking big deal that was
a big deal that is like super annoying
oh my God okay this is great is a great
tutorial
greater than becoming an answer by yes I
agree
future Harris or cancellation images
which I think I already just downloaded I
already I have it Monday but I'm doing just
as soon as that man has found that list of
packages ya got you
maybe Wade we have to download the key when
files and said the ISO files right
chemo users who want to download the IMG
files okay so I don't have the right thing I
was going to use I was going to use the
Linux Mint I was going to see if you could
do then
and I don't think Linux Mint has an empty
file to use chemo with Isis and I am G's
argument Carrick house I guess I must be
able to ever has already been doesn't know
what does not is there is a man of his
father packages about the loan snaps can
bite me images for twin sister lost in the
cloud appointment cloud in it
I want to do that Nevada sources no don't do
that
his birthday yesterday.
I didn't I didn't see if I have snow or
whatever y'all for the command
if I probably can use to boot a C B virus
and an open source bios invitation
well that was a problem before it came up
with rock you count to is it was was raw
yeah I know
yeah but look we don't want to talk about
that because I m g why is it I am Gianna and
then why isn't nakyuka I'm going to named it
wrong and screw this up because we were
trying to confuse a convert the IMG image
into a kick out to image and it was already
if you count and I didn't trust file the
report the right thing which turned out it
was so if I'll come in and so this is kind
of the problem you're having me for a 24
hour on that shit trying to trying to give
trying to look at the Oak Winery in the
button just try to figure out what the
fucking file was
the firmware with kiwis to boot setting
things is to send me Lisa's using a carriage
return a long I had to make a deal with that
but this is only for the cloud-based images
right
I think it's only for the cloud-based images
I'm trying to
I know this is stupid and it's not normal
but I won't ask you to boot a desktop image
and that's a Starbucks kind of thing to do I
get it or vagrant or whatever
as it matures now a load-bearing bug
yeah it is yeah it is it really is
well now we know about it right away so SSH
I almost got stuff is because we were trying
to use cloud-based images I don't want to
though
give me a system machine that they have the
BIOS to get up we were trying to get our
stuff to do and it wouldn't do it because it
was going to buy a house and so I actually
thought he got something let me know if it
was taken care of for us
is there a Staples KVM type of Q35
but I'm not at PCI NFL week 10
actually the whole team of command like yeah
it does but it'shusband is also fucked
Burt manager is fucked on my machine because
fucking route
so watch imma do it again Universal machine
measure myself
forward going to go find a nice happy then
it's been 64 should work no problem until it
it's a bunch to
we do this again so people can understand
why I'm going through his pain and suffering
I basic stuff here right forward and credit
disc makers of faults. Whatever it's going
to try to build it and liver images right
which is all fine and good
when click on customize this
Katie and I just been keeping Rex 84
emulator chipset bios
I didn't exchange that sounds off formation
about two CPUs
can I sit here to Pieology no food options
I'm going to turn it in with many one last
time right now
her desk cancel know we were to do the thing
again
I don't remember what it wasn't your doing
beginning solution is going to fail though
because it can't is a Nexus because it it
created the images route
I fuck this fuck it fuck it in the ass until
you do it
I know I was going to fuck me over if imma
do it anyway
cuz I just want something I can get Shu I
don't care about the file system permissions
cool
likewise immediate volumes is who want only
cinnamon
ethics that give me a second I know I found
the bug for it
your name is Human create raw I know it's
super cool I want to be able to yet
I want to
and I'm not supposed to do this I'm going to
fucking up my lover because I'm doing is
rude but I'm giving a try anyway so there
Android default equals Kimmy system really
haha that is a new trick I have not seen
before
hey lover. I like that trick I hope it works
it's annoying to have to do it but I'm okay
with it
you're right the fault
yeah but pure system is Alexa local I
remember that from terraform
I don't think it will help because we did
this with the telephone stuff but it's worth
a try
Rochelle machine yeah
can I do it wrong your eye
I underscore default thank you very much
human system
I mean it I fucking myself up because I
already ran for it managers route which I
think you got me in trouble in the first
place
I have to restart the video yet sorry
seashell
now I understand Liberty after you explained
it I explained it I understand why that
needs to be restarted so much because it
reads the configuration it doesn't mess with
KVM though
not really anything you could change in the
module
you could change in the module in the KVM
stuff I would think but I don't think much
of their changes except for reboot I can
update to the actual binary
I would think right current manager I mean I
may have missed something but must drive
file new virtual machine I would really like
for this to just accepted a false
amantel I don't I just want to be able to
knock this thing out and get it to work
that was so wrong they're unable to every
month you can maybe I need to put in a
different place now
let's try it in a different place let's
change your volume maybe that the giant the
volume thing of work
a soccer move lasers in the liver group yet
any soccer Vehicles over
well I would not know how to do that but
yeah we can we did that before people were
yelling at me because I was running and his
route and so I tried to do all the work to
change it
at this could be for folder permissions so
we just need to do a Devo and let's see one
thing at a time
but I don't see why why can't I use it if
I'm from it let's try this one chunky cuz
this is all new stuff to jump he's giving us
here this is stuff we haven't tried before
so I'm willing to try anything
yeah I would I would much rather use the
default location which is owned by river who
cares it's supposed to be in the same group
as opposed to work that's the whole point of
putting yourself in the liver group
so is in your yes
he's like a real information so you know
exactly the very kind of
is UNIX talking are weaned Away From Ashes
to New so I can drive versus other account
can I sup you overcome by
are you do think this this needs to have it
in in in and see liver that's this is not
yeah I was going to say
I didn't say okay
I'm going to have to write that stuff down
so if that works let me get to work how to
write it down
is there a Red Sea live Birds
Everts the cough if this works my terraform
local provider Liverpool actually work
oh fuck
I'm an idiot one of the ones that we added
this was this was documented in the bug-fix
so I think you're you're I think you're in
the sink with that
Unix socket group and he's like every right
firm
what was that an excerpt from perms
yeah I was trying to say that those are two
things I haven't done I just read write and
read only
should you read only as well Amazon
yeah maybe doesn't work. Org I don't know
what I'm doing
I need to dive into all that stuff and I
haven't really do want to do that I feel I
feel a little bit about my my liver and
chemo skills have been kind of hit and miss
you know and fill in the gaps I got tons of
gaps in their I need to come back and do an
exhaustive in alerting session for all that
stuff I just wanted to keep you to work at
first time and I got the mentor to work and
I was kind of Happy
isotonix oh God please no
I don't have a c Lenox we actually check
that we thought that might have been getting
in the way at one point
yeah there's a command you can do this
except when you have a similar next morning
and I forgot I actually wrote down
number tens to work out of the box on the
internet and of course it does
that you know added to the list of things
that make you one of his red hat instead you
know
and if that's true
and if that's true that's a really
substantial objective bullet point about
using redhead for your servers instead of
I'm going to
Deseret Red Hat yeah and so they make sure
it works right that all the ansible Dave's
are also a redhead
yeah right so yeah that does make you wonder
is it make you want to listen let's just
take a moment to think about this okay so
I'm going to do a facial zoom in thing is so
do we use red hat because all the system
operating system changes are coming
including ansible
Ann libert and Camus those are all owned by
red hat so do you go with a server the eagle
with a redhead server like most Enterprises
do not just because of the of the server
support at the Enterprise level or do you go
or do you trust canonical to be able to take
care of that level stuff for you
and our right has got an army of support
Engineers yes and I put it on my Hardware if
it was your own Hardware you use Pandora now
that that's okay that's different right so
now you're talkin about a no talking about a
workstation so and by the way I use Fedora
for 15 years 10 to 15 years at IBM for that
very reason all of our servers were red hat
and I knew how to manage red hat and I
wanted to be proficient with red hat even if
I was pissed at redhead for selling out at a
certain point you have to kind of say that's
the way things are done so I'm I mean this
if this works this is the first substantial
Remy truly substantial bug that exist in
Ubuntu that does not exist in red hat if
that's true I'm going to add it to the list
and if the list gets big enough
bye-bye I want to go by Damian and I'll
start to use red hat because the engineering
team over there is much stronger standards
and that is the reality whether you like it
or not that is the reality that's the new
Lenox reality
So based on that
and it lets us asking it but that's a pretty
a pretty inflaming question here what
company is going to provide better
Enterprise of support canonical for servers
canonical or red hat
what company has the strongest engineering
as a stronger engineering team for providing
Enterprise support for their Linux
distribution red hat or canonical
and I think if you remove all bias and
internal feeling out of it depends on the
product gen2 if you're talking about or talk
about servers I'm thinking about
specifically servers are behind so much as
GDP did they do to be too I didn't realize I
did the new GTB when did they start becoming
involved with GTB
Arch there's no Arch on any Enterprise
server in the world
I'll pay you $10 if you can find a
substantial company running Arch on the
Enterprise server anywhere
you can't save a life cuz it's not
black worm I'm not mad
everything about Enterprise server
architecture
I did not know a red hat
what is red I thought she could be was an
independent thing did they take it over
holyshit you've got to be kidding me
they did not take this Susie I love Susie I
use it for a long time
like I had actually has very little
competition in that in that space I agree
that are designed in a way that I disagree
with and have a tendency to do difficult
things that work in I agree I just never
test anything to me I agree
I agree I do not like the architectural
decisions coming out of red hat but the
engineering from Red Hat is stronger
and that is me speaking
is me speaking dispassionately because I
fucking hate red hat but
call Devin to carry at the elves have the
largest numbers, that's absolutely do you do
when people go there if they want to do
anything so if you remember they have a lot
of meteor that develops projects as well
because they can compile their own right
they have a lot of it yam
I think I think I think Jen to until they
can be used as you back from your pretty
face pretty much allows you to inspect
memories anything
funeral dresses that is a very nakroma
switches from Jen to I didn't realize that I
did not realize that did not know that thank
you for that empty inside tell me why as
usual fantastic Community here really strong
container if you're in building or Linux to
show absolutely absolutely it's better than
a real real fast and then following the
instructions
yeah it was inspect memory
how the fuck is this a redhead tool my I
don't
GDP predates redhead by years
someone's got to back up that statement at
Red Hat on Stevie or created it
this pays lot of money to work on it really
I was going to say
yeah
so you're saying that redhead is
contributing a lot to the FSF and therefore
they have core contributors the GB tool a
lot of them
that would make sense but to say but to say
that red hat is or owns GTV
they double charge you for I am as much as I
do my God
they don't all need to be they just have so
much influence over because they bought
their their way to the table meaning they
have the Accord ABS in committing to GB
yeah they maintain the new releases so I
didn't really
control points of GDP they have pretty
significant ones that I did not realize that
she this is like really interesting
information I have to have to summarize as
soon as that
red hats
undeniable I'm going to use your word
control points in onyx
Red Hat created systemd
controls GTV
and did they make live vert and chemo
at least only KVM isn't completely
controlled by by Red Hat as well
are you telling me it is
about the company behind
Red Hat
a long time ago
Michelle Minot everybody's been asking that
mostly it's just consistent across the
border
and red hat is pushing hard with openshift
and pod-man see you control control the
cloud
I need a new space as well
as much as you might hate
where they are taking things their control
over the Enterprise Market
is nearly at Monopoly
have proportions especially considering
there
affiliation with Iron Man and Enterprise
affinity for big
companies with huge contracts that they can
call upon for support and blame when things
don't work
in other words red hat
like it or not is Enterprise Linux
I don't like writing those words
oh yeah oh yeah believe me don't even get me
started to send him with something yeah
if you want to work in Lenox or and or
cloud-native
any Enterprise
you cannot avoid learning a redhead
even if you use something else on your own
another thing I could be changing my answer
will mess
and ansible
I mean I don't like Friday yet but
he might cancel this around a bunch you
might be authentic sorrow equals none and
Eagles none since this is a local single
server machine
yeah
those are very saranghae Maza here we go
calm down we're going to keep calling and
just accept reality unfortunately
Sao Paulo
Enterprise on a redhead
I had to accept the harsh reality lately
all right
Grantsville Python 2.7 can you please tell
me how I can get off if you want something
all right so I'm going to go ahead and post
that
that's what you give me in here I think I
did I cannot believe they got control of GTB
he's at every day for years is there a
little support trying to find Tilly bugs
that's it that's huge
it's happening cuz you know people argue
about distros and shit and you know when do
managers and on YouTube and letting
intervention here we are talking about the
equivalent at a much greater
much greater scope with regard to the
Enterprise who has control of the Enterprise
you know it's a different conversation at
the elemental as in Wild
it's just so much just such a different tone
this is part of my doctor tried it resists
red hell yeah
Christian Ponder and yeah I think I'd rather
buy a note using keep him in the red hat
hatred for going somebody said that's why
they don't support him cover templates and
stuff
that is a key to making your own little
sister of yeah they did actually they did
use KVM we just read about that they
modified kavian
now there's an elevator debugger alternate
Melody beef Virginia Beach that yeah I've
heard about that too
yeah I know dgb's kind of old school who
Shot Ya
I just hate going they built all over she
thought it was somebody said you were the
one who was telling me that they support PVP
samples but they don't fit they don't
support go template for filtering criteria
on. Unplug men like like dr. Trying to
select a specific thing you want to filter
the output you can use going to put us in a
filter method and they don't care what use
PHP template filter for me but they don't
like she's going that's one of my pet peeves
and I was going to try these five men s r
subscript
yeah yeah that was supposed to be thing that
fights already passed it's not even worth
talking about anymore
after a police raid index card and I have
her every kind of b a l a m a great as
Library regular controls yes yeah well I
don't know why he's for new project running
mobile
good job we in the right place
what kind of live and breathe out all day
everyday I'm going to play with her when I'm
not.
Interesting I I just yeah
do I think that's enough motivation for me
to change my default workstation OS to be a
redhead system
I don't know
God knows that they don't put as much
attention to their desktop distributions
over a redhead
they're all about the server over there
I can't see any reason to do that it really
feels like canonical is fulfilling what Mark
shuttleworth said we're going to make desk
but we're going to make Lennox to the
leading desktop distro they never gave a
shit about servers and it to this day it
seems like Chronicle really doesn't give a
shit about servers they don't care. Just the
only reason that a bunch of server became
popular was because people were using it on
their desktop
I am going to run for four years to but if
you do
yes it's the newest to it but if you can
as Liberty change help in the try thank you
for that reminder
system citizenship I did nothing back yet I
mean you went with none later right
I need your help going with none instead of
to fit none here
I got it back I got to go back sorry for
that I should have done it when you said so
yeah I'll talk to you tomorrow
okay that was there and the other one is in
a tree right right
Elizabeth knows what they already thank God
that we read about that from the bug we we
we've probably had the same bug report that
you're pulling that from
any other name so what's a Porsche
ssj3 if your time in tears are worth nothing
I don't know man it's this is a tough one I
can also use DP Mosaic yes yeah I
yeah I mean if they if their virtualization
is that much easier than the virtualization
so I just was working on a cold stuff and I
might be on board with the red hat change
I just was talking let's go yeah we've been
just this is all over you doing all morning
I know better like yourself as a redhead I
don't know if
I don't know as it's a call I'm not an
officer found at all so but they got a
better engineering team so
enough
I mean if you're the city where you have to
make a decision based on what's best for the
company you got a second to set that shit
aside
I'll finish it exactly
the facts are apps yeah I sort of I mean not
all 12 factors
yeah I'm not a fan of your business what I
haven't been for a while and I support him
for fifteen years and I'll be home in
yes it's about microservices most I think
you help me do my restore here is Sue to
systemctl
restart Levert's d
and what's wrong with that manager is it
running what's rerun it
Hertz manager if I make a new one
I'm exciting as it falls on purpose I'm
deliberately losing the default pool size
and I so much I still think I should be okay
I'm pretty sure chemo or whatever it is is
emulating on top of his son Tommy stop
talking. They should do it
I'm not going to do anything else that's
going to try it with the defaults note still
in the fridge still no dice
hey I went use Emax unless you're working a
large code bases on the same computer and
you're never going to work on more than one
computer maybe Deimos to suffer injury and
then case I can cuz you need to be liking
all my systems
why is the standard editor on all Unique
Systems
and if I was going to say that the edge and
I'm going to say okay Ed turned into
accidentally eyes the original version of XO
there for the is the standard enter the end
given that CB formation around the storage
it will yeah but but she'll make a new
source will I don't do that to write let's
try that now let's try a different one then
we need to pull the fault right mint
I toast right
so I am I think it's okay to have the image
itself be in one of the scera pool locations
and then to have the new
I think I think
horn right Self Storage
it's Ranger Credit Union between you select
a storage in yeah that's why I'm saying that
was his fault so that was the first time we
did this before and it didn't work for that
was in with all our changes so let's try
that no so I want to say I want a great news
custom storage this time was created in the
default pool which have full access to we
did this before and it made an image as
route and then it couldn't access the image
which is consistent with what the liver
provider into a terrifying was failing on so
yeah so here we go we can say yes I want to
do volume and say yes give me a new volume
I don't care we'll see when 22404 finish
arise if you go I didn't do wrong I just
want my two cute cow
how do you say C Conaway I'm just lucky I
guess Brunswick I already did it
hold the phone amantel alright so
actually let's see what this is see this you
see what it did it did the same thing again
it did exactly the same thing the only this
time I'm going to intervene I'm going to
show them that shit
so it will feel it's the same thing it's
just fell before I'm free confidence I
didn't know you can look at it before it
does the actual install
last time
no it didn't work last time either but will
try but yeah are you ready
they said the boot menu actually listen to
see it was giving you a passive permission
to see we might we might have a boot issue
later and we had that before because you
have to check with us at the boot menu on
which I didn't do it
the Finish yes different error
Driver Auto read only true discard could not
open permissions 9
cell dinner restaurants
so everything
get out of 40 song about I am not a fool get
out of the full although I get it I get it
this doesn't work because the it gets
recreated
every mascot I know there's an open Bug
about this and liver is actually showing the
file to its ownership permissions and that's
II again I I kind of left it at the end
there cuz I didn't want to fuck with it
anymore and I'm inclined to do the same
thing here
I doubt this is going to change anything but
let's ride
manage sekou game she's going
horn he's ever known images fine mind can't
unless I run it is rude
I actually think if I do
route manager as root cuz I just want to get
onto the answer will stuff
I know I'm not supposed to do this I know
that don't bud
I just wanted to fucking work at this point
what to do if I think I might have installed
it wrong I need to wipe my OS and do it all
over again it's probably some bug in there
that I'd that's probably my fault I just I'm
tired of it
liver Community Roofing time you off when we
did that I had to put myself in the liver
group I did that
yeah but it wasn't enough so
nope still has that permission even though
it's route
reminder to drink is Rudy still at the
information is who's the owner of the pool
and before the fault or the isopropyl
you ready to be delivered I think you might
be right
is slivered something it was like yeah
I stopped you see a bunch of over it
it's delivered but there's there's another
one besides liver right
yeah okay but okay I don't remember the
group though there's another group we can do
so they went to I talked about
how is it lyric you make a man yeah wait a
Mite did I do it wrong
but if I did I might have trip lever I can't
remember which one it is
he just said user to root group delivered so
I that's what I thought I thought we had it
this is another thing that we were playing
with the other day
so maybe I fucked it up Gmail cough
user where is it
Dynamic ownership this is one this is the
one that we had to fix with a liver should
then I'm going to change file ownership to
match the configuration of User Group above
Yep this is the one
and we put 20 cuz you wanted to keep it this
was actually that was a bug fix this is one
before that's what that back and that's
actually say
I don't want it to be group route
set your is a group yeah I was going to say
that sit your user root users of faults by
the way and a group to let Bert and that
will put me in the same in the same group
right yeah that's what it is I bet you
that's the fix emissions to fix for
everything
I bet you that's a fix for everything
yep all right so now now now now this is a
q., so it is this still get at Liberty
restart it is right
this is the thing I couldn't cuz it's
different to I didn't know if it was still
part of that
yeah Griffith gave him over there at our
group is lindberg's for some reason
and that that was the one they had to do but
yeah
galaxy Alex do
I'm going to remove a bunch of thing because
I wanted to create and one look at the
permissions you know mean
we wanted to do the right thing here imma
try to run it without Root permissions for
manager
transient welcome to the pain
browse this is just the image
thanks mint ISO I hate having to change this
but whatever
where 2
now I kind of want to put it in that
location just cuz
absolute I don't think I'm restarting it
properly
I honestly don't think I'm restarting
properly this is and this is where we left
last time and they said you need to restart
your computer to get it to work right now is
like why and everybody was saying because
it's a KVM thing and it's in the colonel and
I was like well that's would mean that the
colonel is being saved differently or
something or that we don't have a clean
install there's a lot of things about me
it's all they got fucked up on the first
time so naughty Katie I miss you that's what
I thought that's that's what I thought so
it's possible that I'm not restarting limber
properly hear it let's let's do this this
thing stopped Lynn Verdi
but you can still be activated by whatever
status
Liberty system loaded boom 66
inactive okay it said Jim 62 stop
personalization Damon's so that means it
would have brought up the name is David has
to run his route right
and I started back up again so we've been
very explicit by that
and what do a bunch of we would do a bunch
of fool
verts a manager make a new one
new forward
I didn't say I think I fucked up my install
some now and something about what I have
here is wrong I don't want to waste people's
time
I am going to fly on a fresh install of
meant for my desktop I might consider going
with Jordan so actually
because I just use internal anyway so no
problem with that is like it really sloppy
with my apt stuff
I didn't reboot you wanted me to do that
they wanted me to reboot you're the one who
kept saying that I was like what you're
saying is different than What proportion of
her somebody was saying was I can't remember
but you know it was was a fortunate result
I can't remember the name
terraform is an 04 if you're going to use
liver provider because liver is broken on a
bun to
now I can see our teacher know it's pretty
fun huh
when is red hat for Roblox to just work out
of the box and require no config changes
what at this point chunky I mean you're
pretty much convincing me to run for Nora's
my desktop go to system because
but then but then I have to give up things
like Witcher
so you know
anyway and suppose not making a witness
trying to get a fucking VM created using
chemo and not happening
I've gotten anywhere because of the distro
and I got you know so those powerful brains
in the business here hey it worked
what do we last change we did something it
worked
it totally worked at time group eagles live
right with a restart
you think it was real people Albert you know
what else it was oh God
that's like mint like oh my God it's alive
all right everybody like fries because I am
I know you're going to hate me but I have to
document what we just did right now if I
don't do it I won't be able to do it again
we're keeping the tradition of yay
I believe the one fix that did this is as as
jumpy as been saying and I was wanting to
test last night but I did I gave up is
change the group and also did you notice we
use the default pool location yeah
veress H list
was it pool what was that other one. Coolest
we did is Assisi till stop and start and we
did not do a restart
alright so
in short with the socket permissions
he will start you think all that stuff had
to be there
you think that all of it had to be there
ohmygod now
if you think all that had to be there then
we're going to go to say that said create
I'm going to fix for
Lynn verts
Gmail
and vert manager
I was going to put down
from chonky seal
yephuman system group Eagles delivered
make sure you add your user to the vert
a group and
log out and log back in
you'll know because groups
I will list it and you'll be able to create
vm's using
virt-manager without
ramanujan went through it without any other
major changes
this is yeah I don't know
hey girl
well here's the thing this this makes me
want to try or terraform stuff again
and you know what I mean
we were trying to use their phone with a
live bird provider and I think we might have
just fix it if we did then we can go back to
try or turn from a local system instead of
using it as a separate thing
group Eagles liver and when you are in
default equals Kimo system
constant function I'm just going to dump a
bunch of stuff in here
yeah if you remember him
this stuff is this stuff is all I know is
this I was in
yeah yeah yeah yeah set
I don't know if it's I think it's a bunch of
the news that mr. extremely I do I think
it's
yeah yeah it did it definitely did
so
yeah and it's this is I bet you Tara Firma
work no problem now
yeah I don't know
I don't know if there's even if it is I know
the terraformed stuff we here's the problem
K I got all the stuff installed invert
Manager work fine I was able to create memes
right and then I tried use TerraFirmaCraft
beams and it couldn't do it and that was
when we hit all of the problems with libvirt
using having tear from try to talk through
the socket and it cuz it says chemo system
as a source in terraformed and I think the
reason it couldn't work is because it was
interacting with liver differently than Bert
manager was by default when it first
installed because I was successfully tell
him I'll tell you I was successfully able to
create virtual machines using Levert manager
as root and no problem and then I got out of
it and I can still do it and it wasn't until
I tried to use her phone to do it where I
set the provider as chemo system that it
started having a big problem a while
thank you for that and so
that was the thing yeah
big thanks 2 Champs
seal from our church community
yeah
oh my God he's Avenue
a soccer formations yeah I think that's why
I think I honestly I think I was in shock
but I think
innocent 2024 yes I love chess I just suck
at it it's been for a long time since I
played I saw trigger playing the other day
androidtv.com right set it seal in
Gmail
no now you probably kick my ass which is
totally fine but I got shit to do like a
fuck around ansible I mean come on I start
at 12 and I still don't have an answer
believe in running because I can't get
infection see I'm treated because I'm so
pedantic about the good news is that I'm
going to try terraform again tonight I'm
going to try terraform again tonight in fact
I might try it
as as as maluma said it is so much more
important for us to learn how Linux virtual
machine to work then to get ansible to work
so I don't mind going down the travel base
especially since we have people that are
Colonel Deb's in the audience are helping us
out like chunky yeah I must be of couldn't
yet that's going to stop me
I don't know with following
group equals Lynn vert
this is Liberty
are you sure it's liver. Kampf instead of
liver d.com
that's really nice Boca Raton focus on
I do get bored all the time last night I had
a big. I'm bored on those watching movies
I get to Preston board like everybody
I like why the fuck am I doing any of this
what's the point what's the point
the good news is it will have this document
it for the next time it's live Burt. Come
Friday
are you going to have the phone right
this is when we was config good cash okay
thank you yeah
all right so you all right with you all
right at fault
think I got them all right
and if in a shoe box of Ashes to dream of us
well you could change the globally but we
didn't other people
the post track me all that was nice
that's great thank you for fun I like for
Acme it's gotten better it was in its Lennox
model it's kind of shity at first but then
gotten better I'm more of a fact about just
coming up
coming up we are going to do security
analyst stuff in November next year
we didn't go over the wire recently it's
best to bods on there they're going to
rotate out after 60 days if you want to go
watch him you want to watch me suffer
through it
but they are there they're out there
somewhere I think I got everything
I think I got everything
pop OS woman to keep meowing
bugs when Birds Kimu
and I'm going to go is that link chemo
but all this is on the other links he even
came out look up default volume on TV
running lab said it came over troll
I have a another one set link terraform
proxmox a terraform at home
why don't somebody we did another one it
isn't an ansible one
circular saw at the fault
yeah I mean it's a bunch of stuff here
how do you make a tag system is that that's
a big question
I mean you can go read and all the stuff I
read about that he was trying to learn about
cybersecurity
over the wire I like over the wire
go to order wire. Org band it is pretty fun
I did a whole thing on it if you want to
watch it
Degreaser service for Xbox Live backwards me
to I agree I completely agree
oh right right right
and I'm going to put that big ol anthesis on
this morning
all right
Hitman working Nash CD-ROM for ISO
and provide a disc you have him sell it to
do it directly very very cool you got to
work hey fresh yeah
Lenox nice yeah I just I only use Witcher
wish for TF2
yeah hip I think that's it
so so there's my notes on that they said
send me the correct if I got it wrong
so hopefully that will help people that went
out to Twitter everything I'm going to stand
up and take a quick little break
I need my bladder needs a break if I can
no I'm at more punctual these days used to
not be at all
all right
I went to the break come back now I'm back
I'm back I need to go to the restroom and
stuff
yeah I got offered greater I got off work I
think technically yeah I delete the whole
fucking thing
but my I still have an account over there
for my skills that company and I can't
manage to get an account and so I took it
all the shit from people trying to sell my
me executive services for my company in like
I I hate Lincoln I wish I had never ever
gotten on it
so I have a feeling that this rabbit hole
with doing chemo directly is unnecessary at
least for now so we'll do it later
assistant search
this is somehow to search work it works like
this said query ansible and I use get him
for the searching
I cheat that's how
and then I have my own internal thing him
Cindy said in an easy fix it it's got
problems but him
alright so
answer the question why ansible instead of
just a bunch of shells for a reason that I
already did that I need to write about
anymore if you don't know why
the short answer the tldr is because that's
what everybody uses to configure systems.
It's modular and it lets you do stuff that
just works cute little kids
yeah Nicki Minaj it's no video chat with you
okay so great a virtual machine somehow
trifling you presently using
virt-manager here on Linux you're on Linux
it doesn't matter as long as you get at this
age
Sophie finally figured that step 5 hours
later
and also few things to put away such as
yourself package got files
would you advise your car identification
with a new system this is crude this is
trivia
Universal machine is in Cuba directly no
fuck that fact you can die I don't need you
anymore I don't need you anymore because why
I have this Halo people I have a Linux Mint
system ye now it's just is Anthony the whole
school install here I'm going to go ahead
and go for it so if if you don't know how to
do this stuff just go ahead and install look
for any of the information I have allowed on
how to install Kimu and which at the time I
didn't realize was a bigger than that it's
also install liver manager and
that was based on another sheet or else you
got to find out actually I think I have a
lab on it
that find
chemo so I mean cuz I don't want to leave
people to watch it right now. How did you
get that on there
set up Kim over some machine on Linux so
this is the one said chat this one so that
that one has the instructions about
about that so sexy lab came to set up did I
actually type it that way please tell me I
didn't God damn it
if it's that way I'm going to be really
embarrassed
and God good the link is broken things I got
to do just the link and that
all right so that that that corrected it
that's another reason not to use of water
because it's so you know he can fix it on
the Fly and it just gets fixed I'm actually
let's go for it we're going to sell mint on
this computer
an English Rose makes me happy I just say
this makes me so happy I'm like
reminded how much I love mint
English to English
continue I don't like I'm sitting at all
it's to cover fighter login
yeah I fucking hate it but I do know that it
works with the phone and that's the part
that we get suppose people in this way they
use it which I eventually want to work out
it's almost half a multimedia codex I don't
really need them but if you want to be able
to play stuff you probably need it that's
proprietary that's why they asked you that
so you can do dcma kind of stuff
erased is going to sell a smooth again this
is not going to be your coldest it'll be
just a disc for this computer this virtual
machine something else no I don't want to do
my own thing I love meant I just really
really love it just saw your key for file
system on a virtual disk
yeah the one thing I'm still missing from
his other cast in his I can't use it with my
phone remotely that's a big big deal
so I need to fix that it's one of the many
things I love actually had robbed
let's call it VM
I meant Rob Senate SSH has two different
username password password
I think login automatically sure
now we're kind of password no I'll get it
back Lee
come home folder and now I mean these are
all I say is a workstation normally I would
do a server for this stuff but why not you
know
I can give you in have a good deal no
urgency also no
I don't think it would
you know anything or see first without any
cplusplus
they're totally different languages they
might
they might be competitive plus plus might
allow you to write see but if you write C
and C plus plus many people would say you're
doing it wrong at no more than me including
Striker
go talk to some of the sheep was supposed to
be a totally different language thinking of
them as the same language is a huge mistake
in my opinion
supposed to be friends for starters and see
is imperative and sometimes functional
that's the first big difference
they put that in job postings because they
don't know better
I am calling you on that junkie I am totally
quoting you
that is so late getting a quote quote
that's funny
adem
alright procedural imperative same thing
imperative and procedural are closely
related she can be functional as well
and if she has procedural or or or
functional medicine imperative language is
like if this then that
I tend to me imperative is the opposite of
body of reprogramming it's like this that
easiest way to say
yeah there's a little bit of overlap in your
Paradigm specifications are I think I can
have that wrong but can I ask why I was
going to use the right for everything
I didn't Auntie monks I thought it is for
everything
as I'm making a power call Jala calling
geek jokes that make me laugh times a day or
even a week that I would actually belly
laugh
since I started screaming I might get really
upset and need to pet masi to get my some my
blood pressure down and stuff like that but
I want to tell you since live streaming and
meeting is
band of Misfits I have belly laughed more
than I've ever been laughed in my life
because you're so fucking funny your jokes
just make me laugh so it is hard to find
people that actually make me laugh that much
and I really enjoy it so there thank you
I respect you I really love it
he said Festival I didn't think we need to
send anymore
when was Justin about our Tokyo this is a
good one you have but we don't need any more
apparently this one anymore
how does tax search work it doesn't text her
she wasn't working right now it only work it
only serves just had her in mind
unless you can get him then today searches
the whole body text continue testing restart
now
damn that was fast that was fast
why do I get the feeling that this is going
to be a lot faster overall then running
virtualbox
I mean that's that's my press removed
insulation in the front center
it's going to see the installation media
again I have a feeling
yeah because he knows that the volume I
might have to go on Mount the volume in
route manager
I think which I don't know how to do all
thing to learn how to do that if that's true
even it even uses the same sound drivers and
blue everybody's ears out
where was actually learning at school today
and work nice
well we're getting very close your system is
currently running without video Hardware
acceleration he may experience for
performance so nice if you shouldn't I don't
plan on using Graphics at all
I wonder if they're
I wonder if there's actually drivers for
this this is where we would start playing
around with pastor and stuff like that which
is not critical to what I want to do today
but at some point when I come back and do
that
does not need any additional drivers you
think so huh I mean it's pretty damn fast
I feel like I'm going to play like a game
from hers and I could probably try it though
watch me break it
I should have died so I don't know very
usable
sound
I'm just trying to see in the desktop
environment
if I'm going to be able to do it or not hey
look my fault
super ugly terminal the running Linux inside
of Linux running mint
inside a populist right now we're running
mint inside a populist
just cuz we want to I think about this as I
can show people how to set up their servers
and stuff
we've been interested in a decision around
here at so I can do ansible for it
I think open a stationary installed I'm
going to do it from the command line
Jenny told her I don't even know that I need
a full graphic enable VM
it doesn't do my default yeah I remember
that
yeah so if I try to connect to here's my IP
right
I over here and I at the sage to it oh God
God damn it that's right I forgot cut and
paste doesn't work yeah I forgot about that
always on top and Sage
6/8. 22. 101
I know you have something at work there's no
SSH though
yep there's no Staples Center to work
station right so it doesn't have it but what
if I don't have to install it
apt install openssh-server I think
hi how's it going it's your grandma
we're installing openssh so true or false
when using
ansible you must have SSH configure
so it
and this using one of them I don't even know
they had how's it going I did not know what
when our m is a remote to a dossier on any
system in order to get to work so so what so
let's say
Melissa's the current system password
now I'm going to do a thing a magical thing
with SSH y'all probably know this right
copy ID this will actually make it so I
don't have the password ever again
for better or worse
and then I can do it again I just get on
there
you need the IP is going to be the same
every time I boot up pretty sure that's
consistent sure so I can go
yepwhat hey how's it going Switzerland
you probably like everything else when your
horse is falling hosts
weather in SS in a switches that guarantees
can always be the same interesting
and please tell me I don't have anything
here that I shouldn't show
I'm scared SSS
I see you can sense if you have name and its
relation to what that need any IP you don't
need it right above got you
find a horse to add it
you should have had a phone CVS ISO savion's
IP for husbands on my son's name
I'm going to have Dad mine right you send me
pictures of a new nameservers Switch
functionality yeah they did you let me see.
This new I haven't done is work
yeah this is cool
let me see the ad
lizards I guess is rude yeah okay
verts s a group right yep limbert
Ojos oh okay I'll try that
hosts here we go
not found equals return hose files minimums
Muse my machines
I rather in your home house
I know I've heard about it at some point it
will but this is just on my own machine
machine right so host gets when he gets kids
verts all right I guess I didn't know there
was it was more than that
Brenda b r t yeah that's cool
all right love our guest okay
but let me know how they even know to go to
it
and we try to oh the name the name may be be
be be be remade I get that with the various
ageless right
so as his age 12 no completion bud
there's no I made it wrong device or
resource busy
is right let me go see if we can find out I
probably have to restart the name service
right I guess I I do
that came out wrong I'm dying to live
do I need to donate to put it there all
right fine
we can't imagine guests stay for some
research and machine
and sign the modules really easy a maybe I
don't have a no I do have it on and it's
going to take a shower for the Virginia's
a suspect has been arrested for me looking
for the whole user is trying to get through
files module has consulted
I can just a lot he also but that's kind of
better for other stuff
much like the only only host name is
provided by guest
do you think the hostname goes here
I think so it's 8 p.m.
what I don't have r.e.m.
Vienna by ybn nahmiroh we what you mean the
name
oh because I needed the hostname VM got you
got you good I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm
glad
I need the address though but I still needed
to add delivered right
I need to put that in here
adding named solution to Kimu
liverworts
shein mysterious person busy
if I try to fix I didn't restart okay fine
go updated while I'm doing other stuff my
updates
I probably missing something
yeah yeah I mean we'll find it we'll find it
interesting for me to actually press charges
but you do need SSH
oh God atom editor BusyBox
eBay systemd all dates this could take
forever
all right so that's up stats updating yeah I
mean it's play with it I think it's worth
playing around with I didn't know it existed
so
alright so
it does make me wonder if ansible is going
to want that though
you know I mean we want these dominions
anyway oh that's a testament to block game
I'll go back and add more till later I just
had to make a make a reference to
maybe a limber tree still restart probably
right
Anniston City Jail
this resource busy current results p.m.
oh wait it's still running
I'm not sure restarting is working they the
truth I got a part of the problem
so 22 22 22
and use connection I try to do it when I
white ass naked pig
oh I'm tried it we're just right and where
to find them Birds SSH
and I think it is rebooted it actually so so
that's what happened
turn off yeah your system is up to date
reboot a required if you want to switch the
look on there no man this brings back
memories
that just really see the fox say we shall
find out in a second may god restart this
Sea-Doo shut down Dash
I should do that tomorrow but whatever
bershka virsh
DHCP leases default yay
hosting VM is have it easy for this yeah
that's what
yeah
so so livid that doesn't make any sense to
restart Liberty by restarting the system so
that it grabs the right dfcp least make
sense right
I see what you're saying yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
all right let's go ahead and start this baby
power it on
I am so happy to have her, she's running old
guy that's allowed did you hear that or did
I do in Terraria
I guess we don't want to remember to know
I'm so sorry if I haven't
it's really loud and I woke up here for your
dog
damn it spoiled again
didn't even hear what I needed I think I
need to be right
I think it is I think it is
no sound things me too
I'm actually really impressed that the sound
drivers work
because too often they don't write like a
virtual boxer VMware or something and they
got better out of it for a long time they
did not work at all
I mean I'm totally okay just making an SSH
config entry but I kind of want to figure
this out
so
I don't need you anymore even though I I
will come back to the chemo install from the
command line at some point I definitely will
I just don't want it for now
Disney value with you yeah
well yeah I'm surprised this weekend's
running without killing in a lag or anything
she's doing fine now
I mean to write we can play around with with
the VM setup or not
and it says such got called is a
configuration video game server switch
functionally
if you have do the duck represent info
practice I'll try and flipsy name service
switch
yes I have hosts
files the rest let's try that
yeah I know this might have been worth
getting matched first right
we have we have a link to that somewhere
Redfin
LS on it I thought it and then it where is
it
I know it's let's start with one thing at a
time so live vert
group Hertz guest start there
now do you think that's going to need a new
DHCP lease
the NSS thing I don't know how to restartI
restarted Liberty I thought it was in her
it's not it's in anything
systemctl
crap and us and it's look up
immunization Stanis look up in a teaser
what's a subsystem
might be a little bit I don't think it's a
computer almost positive name Services I've
never had yet
it is three of us search that's fantastic
yet
yeah I have a question for you on some of
that stuff we have you ever been terraformed
to do your own local configuration I need to
go back to it but if you do let me know I'd
love to compare notes
about to reboot my whole computer just to
restart named Services I will cry like a
little baby because that would mean my dream
of Linux has died
the best hair for me to ever have you done
everything you said you remember you told me
you paid like five bucks for a cloud space
or Cloud configuration time and stuff I'm
just wondering if you tried it with your
form on with Dropbox or anything local
hey there's some Rust Asians doing stream
planning and writing in Open Office
sounds about right
haven't been terraformed I love you I need
to go to xcp-ng to get around yes
yeah well that's that's okay yeah we can
compare notes when that comes up I want to
see if I can if I can practice my terraform
skills on a local cluster or even just like
a local remote server that's got multiple
course that's kind of the goal you know
by the way everybody doesn't know it is like
a kick-ass streamer who who is running a
little professional meet up and all kinds of
stuff hasn't been screaming for one couple
months now 3 months or so and I found had
just wandering around when one evening and
I'm super glad I have so make sure you fall
head
when it when it comes like virtualization
and things like that it's more than me most
people everybody but but yeah
I don't know about that cut
okay if you say so
do you think your parents ever since I mean
you know there's lots of people here there's
lots of streamers actually they did do this
but it had told him once he was interested
in the same kind of operations that I am
so what is next we have
obviously we need to restart in a services
and I don't know which one it is so
restarting
ins which is probably a fur and is this
is there a demon I need to restart hey it's
the first hit
I know you probably don't and if you wipe
keep playing Torres it I have not heard
about YP bind in 20 years that's on my plate
with wifey and all that is so that's what
Yellow Pages that's the old school systems
for DNS
a senior Bridge what bridge are you talking
about
ins confound figured you may have nscd
nameservers cash and David running which you
may need to receive this unlikely
yeah I was trying to get in we already did
it was just keep doing it until it works
that's not the definition of insanity that's
how Unix works
so that would be a no
you need to set up a manual bridges that is
the fault of the liver I've no idea what you
just said I know
I know can she definitely doesn't do that
it's still a fair that's why I'm laughing
because didn't work like that
right now I'm like I'm losing patience
because it's like we're five hours and I
still haven't done anything with asthma
does it really work
is that could that be messing with it
actually that might be messing with it I
have it at SSH config
is it the same IP please tell me star Play
song is not the same IP I think it is a God
how would it know to God
IPA ratebeer but not the right command holy
shit it's 131 again when I give it a
different IP anytime right so I don't want
to depend on the icky
I actually need to spend time doing this
always against which happy every time so we
don't want that we don't want the face
picture saying like me every time
I don't know it wasn't
I think I did wear one this last week but I
don't know if that I know it he also or 1 so
hey how's it going bro
I'm doing something wrong you absolutely can
ask a question you don't need to ask a
question to ask a question
what's shall we look at
I'm going to go bigger than this yes Center
of your chest it's been awhile but
yeah maybe some people here know about it
they can help you more than me
well what is ovh for everyone else
Chicago no no I thought we had something
else I tell you about the cloud provider
I don't know about that one
I thought retirement something else ovh is a
format for
I want to say configuring sound resources
from a long time ago
I didn't make Ivy yeah I don't know why I
don't know I don't know why that's not
something I can answer there might be
something here you can
is your driver DNS yep that's what Imma do
remember your whole said he was a guest to
be on my feet and feel this way because I.
We didn't know I absolutely know I can do it
because I've done that before I would be
super surprised if not I mean it's this is
this is what I mean you know
on the verge of doing cuz I know it works
hey look at that I'm on and it didn't take
any other things to do I'm going to keep
doing that for today I don't I want to I
want to move on I'll come back to the name
stuff later
is spend
extra time to get consistent name resolution
to your
yam IP or not
I didn't I just sent up an SSH I cheated
I took the I text and don't know where I
normally would have done it right I just put
it into Sage now every time SSH goes It goes
the right thing
I think it doesn't respond to call Jim I
know this works cuz I already did this 2
days ago so you just fake file and this is
another way yet another way to resolve those
names when you don't know it
can I pee and I have a feeling that if I
restart my virtual machine that I'll get a
new ID because the DHCP lease and so it's
not a it's not a good way to do it long term
lunch I might want to have it I don't want
to have to sign it but then again you're
getting into nslookup in the Suffolk times
so I wanted to talk to Basile is what we're
doing now I needed an update but it may have
took a while
is obviously something needs to restart it's
not taking it I don't know what needs to
restart so
when do we want to try one last thing do you
really want to
I can move this to temp for now and
I don't know how to cook a how do I restart
DNS name services on
I want to am I need to be installed how do I
restart genius mask
this is when I said it doesn't need it
I guess you got to be so rude network
manager it's the network manager
you really think it's the virtual machine is
going to do that
yeah we did that already
it sent us our Bridge For Recess all good
so when it actually works that they gave
so let me get my advice or the network
manager I might lose you y'all
if I like this is a pretty hard hardcore
restart
and there was already a season-low. Never
cracker
yeah it does it does raspberry Falls it was
really nice
network manager you think liver needs a
restart
I remember restarting network manager for
different things
is it be fully off restart Levert between
that would mean
hey if that works and that means liver
so I have a question is are the Network
Services reconfiguring associated with liver
directly or are they generally just on the
system anything on the system has resolution
of the system right around the edges
yeah it is never an SOS liver and assess do
I have that installed I think that was part
of the things that I smelled I do believe it
is only make sure I have it
well this is one way to know
whoops Thunderbirds
SM box just for manager
earnest then SS
it's fine
SSI Levert help
hey look at that we didn't have it
got you
oh I'm sure it will help that will help a
lot now that it's been installed
yeah I got it I got to go to my list of
stuff to install uninstall Kimu cuz I'm not
going to remember
I wonder was already there I looked like it
wasn't zero of graded so I think it probably
restarted
I have to read this right now or I'm going
to get
a circular machine yeah CD CD ROM
you said don't I didn't I did not it's not
here
there you go I went to restart vert top
vert top is a thing I did not know her top
of the thing
Airbnb in a top like to E
earlier are you stuck in the series that are
using kill us I don't know the answer to
that there's Bridget seals I bet that's the
one that fix their bridging
hello my love you look really good in that
in that Patagonia thing
what is that laundry that's all new extra
miss last night half of it was already was
in the bathroom sorry
are you sad I'm actually changing clothes
more now my wife is looking defeated
I'm stuck in the cia's where you can kill us
yes we do that right okay document
cologne build ad
it's probably there I don't know Adam what
do we call it live
SS Ford tool in furnace off
yep get push that's in the chemo setup
thingamabob
and I already moved the other one out so
yeah they are they're awesome oh hey look at
that
what do you know it works and there was no
SSH config cuz I move did so
here's what we learned software doesn't work
until you install it
put that that is a clip that definitely
needs a clip
oh I would have known that I did not alright
so
we was this now that's like something we did
long ago
have you tried installing it I should have
been but it wasn't cell
so there we are
. I'm kind of happy we got it to work though
cuz I feel I feel like we Master Did We Beat
It we beat it or yes
take me to money thank you for that I
appreciate it
install
software app to do at insult words. We got
lots
that's fine Samurai
there we go I'm super excited I like new
software
I have one whole thing running oh my God
it's so exciting
HD 25% memory points are 1% of see if you
can't Dam
this is when Isis tells you whether your
over-provisioning is going to kill you or
not
I am like that that is a great idea thank
you for sharing that thank you for sharing
that
thank you very much Lee very quickly
approaching the step where we install and
use ansible
having streamed for 4 hours and 32 minutes
and 24 seconds
reduction instead of install ansible but I
mean come on
it just works now it's a 6 p.m.
I was like really really amazing now I
really do
is that as you're in a switch look now mr.
extremely just for the sake of science would
you probably put it back to where it was
before when you think
unforgiving racial that we did we I do not
regret for one second please do not
misunderstand I am totally happy doing what
we did I feel like I'm a little sad I think
it was something much more valuable than
certain that ain't going as well I am kind
of curious though what happens if I put
these over here
I don't I don't know would be really
surprised if this makes a difference but I
kind of want to try it
and I don't know if I had to restart my
machine or not I didn't look like I did
before
is it okay to compare what we have to do
before yeah so there's nothing to really
restart there so it's this HPM we are there
cat dammit box in fast. Fast that it is such
a fast login
I approve I approved after that
next we're on to next isolationist
read me
it's the same it's just the order and I
think you're a baby cute Irish it's easy I
always have
I teach people to use a colon do you keep
his reliable everywhere but she's used
faster to type so
yeah that's that's why you don't see me as
much
yeah I'm still really locked into a control
up bracket for my Skype instead of my remote
cats walk but my fingers don't remember it
I've been using shift lever bracket for
years
which works on everything you don't you
don't have to fuck around with them or see
something
what what what what what are we doing we're
installing animal they even have it how do I
install and civil I need to find an exit or
I think we have one here
7 Q in a bun two went to see how I actually
I'm going to smoothies sue me
they don't belong there this is ansible this
is not chemo so
permit me if I didn't spend time to document
this stuff I would be
unable to repeat it so Kingdom Hearts Wiki
as all of my resources for chemo that I've
used in the past
that's what I have already got a couple
times all right let me say that
Renee add more
reading resources enforce I don't think I
tagged this snow
alright thank you for permitting me to do
that ansible Playbook
yep okie dokie
installing ansible I'm adding it to my
related section
oh my God oh my God
is there an update hey you know what people
we're going to have to write our own
installer for ansible
anybody knows me knows that I'm talking
about
God dammit I know we have a few pee in here
somewhere
yeah
Minecraft apps let's do helm
there is coffee install terraform install
ansible
admin associate it's a prereq where is where
is Edmund Associates
I thought it was a great communities is the
standard de facto but we hate him 10 plus is
that correct I don't like him that puts you
can't avoid them a lot of times yes but I do
still have to understand Helm Helm is still
required to get the the ccat it's on the
test now
so you have to learn it I just don't like it
they have to
and some all right so here's
I'm going to keep this around cuz it's old
stuff that might be relevant
and we're going to Pace all right go down
here
I mean I mean this is this is pretty
standard stuff I don't even know if it's
worth
after updating software, properties Tony dad
this is a a No-No and I'm supposed to do
that anymore I don't even think they support
this anymore
I don't I don't know if they support I think
they stopped
we're going to try it everything about my
admin associate thing
yeah it came it that the Badgers I was doing
absolutely
yeah I think ansible might might be
tell Jamie that works for me if that works
it had them salt look at Addison and Python
3 because I didn't have pythons reinstalled
yeah
all right so let's do
yeah let's do this
what's today's supposed to do get rid of
this
all right that's good enough
0.11 + 5.0
okay we got our install done Afghan TV
Packers game
I don't know why I can't remember why
there's a so that the whole the whole use of
the key stuff is all been change has been
difficult you get a warning on it every once
in awhile I noticed that in that case it
didn't throw the
it didn't throw the warning I wonder if
they've covered up that error
and 50/50 Ansel
I want to take him there
this is something to do with the key
management and just putting everything in a
default key ring without a while ago
I think I'm from an update rather than a
repo pull requests I question how modern the
application is here
yeah I don't know
but this is It's a thing
if you wanted a baby and you have to admit
this is going to talk about her here this
whole receive key stuff
that's changed that's changed if you ever if
they were asking you that but a fault
Summer Jam about that FreeBSD ansible now
Solaris and Swan Arch
slash clear Linux python pip forget that
I don't know it's it's keeps right here the
keys I don't know if it's even worth
bringing up I I don't remember all the
details I know that there is a change from
where you put the keys used to just used to
do add key and just add it won't place in an
owl says that that's a lot of standard and
stars are will tell you the warning they
said don't do that anymore they want you to
create your own separate key in the. Dgpg
key ring and I don't know this has been on
me that's why I'm surprised you didn't it
didn't complain just now because they used
to the PPA add which makes me think it might
have been updated by the district this
distribution that I don't know. I don't have
enough information to go on I just vaguely
remember something related to Pas and their
keys has changed because they wanted to
disassociate from a central key ring
and so she's falling for the modules
you are a mess I'm not doing it like a
former installation okay ansible all that
champagne ask pass would remember him as
long as we choose you can test that it is so
perfectly with the Ping
ansible all that Shannon
being asked us what is it asking for a
password to
what is the password to I'm a little unclear
on that
my password is password is going to ride her
Friday's Hostess is empty only locals is
available note that the implicit localhost
is not match all
okay so Asian King all
a stress medicine
inventory needed we are trying to do some
cooking ratio with ansible
inventory file
edit well I didn't we didn't add in a 2000
way way way
I just says a chance of a hose after you run
a setup
do you need a ring from cuz it's about the
inventory file me Etsy ansible host you can
actually spend some of the inventory file
how to build an inventory of other than a
table
Echo to ansible hosts
does it seriously read from. Ansible hosts
oh I see you can you connect me with
inventory
Kmart Madea Mary file has ever again
it raining right now we're going to say
things are actually aspie
now I canI can figure out ansible it doesn't
happen already and maybe it does
and you could say
as of all house
went to 70. One I think that would be unwise
why don't I just put kind of names here
with that how about that and then
ansible inventory let me know
export ansible
Ansell inventory equals
let's talk big / ansible
air hose subnet it doesn't have that it
doesn't appear to need that
if you have a charger I hope you like lots
of it right okay
wait nice all right so let's do
make sure I can still connect it up and
let's go up here and see what's next
ansible all that's ending
hey it did it
and it didn't have to connect to the
password cuz I did the thing with the names
which is good
discovered interpreter python is a 3.8
change face of a ping-pong is it thing my
God I feel so successful
touch build Vox build a build
check
install why am I doing this cuz I want
something that captures
what I did okay so
so yeah
create a
sue Ed with ansible
this is this is kind of the solution I don't
want to put the solution stuff in the
challenge itself
yeah
and we don't need all this shit but I don't
know man
I mean I could just write it in that right I
don't have to have it run them so we are
done we're ready to start to figuring so I
feel like we're making progress
the fact that we are installed already to go
we're ready to make something and I don't
know if they talk about that here and we'll
go check in
so funny turtles your tag releases
I guess we'll come at Shell completion is
that a thing
wait a second I tell me Angela doesn't have
it
shoot
is it have it does it generate its own I
think I know you know
I cannot add it
orange completion not there
python are complete for maybe you can find
python or can play for me about red hat
Enterprise
Captain pollution you can add insult to my
nine you can add shell completion in the
answer will command line utility by
installing an optional dependency called are
complete our complete support Sebastian has
limits for Target complete
see you at install are complete Hannah B is
a
so wait for me if you don't run out
Enterprise distributions
what what the hell
and symbol what does that do
and it's just a little too and I would not
do that
it will list all the facts of your VM
I was actually JavaScript why are they not
using actual
why are they not using actual job Jason I
guess they are
and now yellow
yeah I'm still looking for completion going
to self python arguably for me then ran in
front of mr. food and or from the standards
of us Rapunzel Ministries
c r r complete documentation
and I can tell Sundance. Are they
oh it's python3 alright this goes into an
installer
Pine-Sol
I'm going to go ahead and run this right now
yes I just did a paste from here sue me
how I just put it here on a shed
Kid Flash tagged
alright so
perfect nail
it's a little accountability African rand
activity Global python are complete
I guess I don't really like that but oh well
I fucking hate python sometimes
not found
if I look at that yeah
what the hell this is a lie
her command configuration email register
python aranzabal C dock
if I can get Amy
I wish people could get it together with a
completion and just used Ashley I can't
believe how what a cluster fuck that is
so how are we going to do we're going to go
ahead and do
oh and has a three at the end
okay
I hope not
I hate doing that but LOL all right now what
ansible still no completion egg sack by
shell
hey it worked all right fine we got our
completion
every single Python program has it now
apparently your bash profile yet
isn't an equation with a Sheltie Sheltie do
not want to do it
play work soon as we can grazing management
language we probably spend some time doing
that
we talked about doing that actually in a
readme furnaces execrate your first ansible
helloworld to monitor those last 5 installs
how'd you do that
what do you mean I added my own custom
helloworld to monitor last night and so sad
you
no I'm not monitoring them I just made a
script that installs them
so that I can just install of ansible in one
command next time still having to go back
and rear-ended so I can't remember
everything
so yeah that's that's how all right
I think we're very close and will be gone
the next thing we almost got it we need to
we need to read about the configuration
language and
ad hoc commands what are those basic
commands working with Play Books
all the stuff I do is public it's all here
oh my God files there's a directory they're
called install
on a server outside of Playbook really shit
I must learn this
play around went ping
and ad hoc commands
to get a feel for how
ansible connects and does things this well
confirm you have a connection as well
bash restaurant was Reva add hot commands
ansible at Holcomb and he's just been
answered what command line tool
I try to make a single tassels on or manage
knows this is like python fabric yeah I'm
super excited by this this I love Fabric and
apparently going to the hood which is to 60
which is that yep yep yep and I can Hazard a
quick easy to do in Tessa v y a
ad hoc home and ansible pattern module
module options
modernist Pantry must be
you can Rob Patterson on other pages I just
kids write a sentence to reboot servers and
Bubba yeah this is stuff we do with fabric
before I'm super happy about this okay so
I'm going to make a thing about this for
myself ansible
ad hoc commands are are
like fabric
on the functionality of
of its much older relative
python fabric remember
Fab files
when do using ad hoc commands
this is good for me because it's something I
can latch onto memory wise to remember
which I love I love looking in rebooting
servers yes I did
is it just a it's just a shade of you
kidding me I'll listen to my not listed in
the group, Atlanta yeah this this is exactly
the same as fabric
I know it's in your getting ready out this
seriously this is this is how I would run my
tests on multiple system using fabric found
files
yeah this is super cool I love this ansible
yeah I'm Nash a l s
it gives our LS this is ignatz exactly what
found files used to do is basically and
makes it necessary to whatever connection
you know
let's do sleep 10
I wonder if it'll do that sounds like a yes
that's not happy it did it
all right so
84 ad hoc
that's that's good I need to write that down
that's the W and order the X right so I feel
like I got it
oh God that lets you
butt implants with only five simultaneous
processes if you have more hoes than the
files at the four count that's awesome
that is really fucking awesome
alright so
this weekend I am so happy I'm learning that
she had no idea this just makes my little
automation hard beat so warmly
seriously I am like obsessed with automation
so this is super happy to me it just makes
me very very happy we waiting for other
question was asked Alicia and you can
connect to server but the reason block I
think I I think this might be one of my
favorite things I've discovered this year in
2022 I'm kind of late to the party as usual
I can't believe I let you become a different
user
yeah I can this is just was just fucking
amazing to me damn
this is this is everything that we used to
do as as using old technology like
I can't remember the name now before
I can expect expect isn't ecl
that's cancel prompts for it the Command
Module does not support extended shell
sensex like popping and rice a little
shelter able to always work
at your command require Social Service in
Texas to Shell module instead and worry
about that with models so far all of our
samples have the Command Module
this is the default model cities are
actually using models and it's a Command
Module that passes that exact that's an
exact call and that's why I can't use a show
cos industrial expansion I just different
modules pass a module named example as well
built and she'll module as we're all I am
answerable to show that she
condemn when are you come out the house but
I talked to you last posed to play books
Temptation test to show courting rules so
that Uncle shower change the variable and
past tense of all right yeah that's because
it's just an exact I just passed is an exit
which is a list of command arguments to the
remote system yeah if I was right I wrote
some stuff like this that would use SSH Once
Upon a Time on that you felt a lot of the
stuff you could have just done with just us
to save so this is just an easier way to do
it hey Tony so
yeah and Atlanta Dash M built-in copy he
find a repeated task like this
Itasca horsepower Mansell and SUV oh my god
seriously
that's M built-in copy that's a source and
destination see why don't you just use STP
for that
it seems like an extra unnecessary layer of
abstraction and she says to pay but whatever
he finally finished now so I can go to the
most because you can combine with other
stuff I have a feeling that's what built-in
file module blah blah blah and Antelope
servers
I see if you can work locally or remote so
can I see p
yeah you're done an excellent your SUV
something and just rename it
cuz you forgot the colon
as well web servers SMS with built-in file
blah blah blue blue blue
changing ownership to the files
at about the five mother can also create
directories accelerate like missing you
Lucci that's that's what the weather is
I look like an accident yeah absolutely yeah
I was still use are asking for that imagine
there's an ansible rule to do that but that
was Sylvia shell scripting in are and arson
called to me
yeah absolutely yeah yeah yeah I think
absolutely does not replace our sink
no it doesn't
I mean if I didn't have ansible I would do
is rsync break
no way to get me to take home I got it
smells so good it's joke with Wally
alright I got to go eat I'm going to go eat
I don't know when I'm going to be back
probably soon though we're making progress
with an ad-hoc commands and stuff so I'm on
my way we made a lot of progress today hey
see you if you guys have to leave for the
night I understand have a great day see you
tomorrow I will be cool working tomorrow I
don't know how much I will be streaming but
I will do some of it tonight later I'll be
applying which were probably in addition to
getting this one this stuff to work
I got the Vodka for sure yeah have K on
and I'm going to stop and get myself 20
minutes but I might be back before then
back back in 2010
okay okay
let's go for it
huh all right
do it supposed to snow on Thursday ohmygod
magic packages
as for web servers built in
as well Milton yeah I miss Wilson Young web
servers managing users & groups
it's obvious in users & groups
it's in service what restart ACP service
Gathering facts and symbol all
I said patterns for a dad who commands and
all the available options putting how to
limit using powers that hog
I told her the only repeated attacks taxes
Ansel playbooks
Hickory eating configuring ansible a
collection so
what are the tasks rightright so this is
where we have to figure out what we're going
to do on this p.m.
and and how are you doing
I still am wondering how to create the VM in
the first place through script
I don't know if Ava need to do everything
you know I you know what let's do the sweet
weed in Sebastopol stuff thank you for that
stuff yeah
well we work we started okay so let me
regroup
recycled to answer those I want to build a
configure things after gets installed right
and I still need to do that but
the bottom line is I want to be able to
bring up a kubernetes environment really
quickly potential at my local machine using
the ATM's that are here and that means
provisioning a bunch of EMS and then
configuring those mediums with all the stuff
they need to be to be a crazed cluster or
just be able to reset on a Dell to reset I
want to go to say hey I want you know 3 or 4
RPMs with nodes and then I want to do them
and that's what vagran has been done in the
past but and is kind of outdated and old and
doesn't work
and that's where Ansel came from I want to
be able to configure my local environment I
feel like I know enough about how to do this
I know what it does and what a play book
looks like I know how to install stuff on it
I mean we could do that we could
we could we can set that part up right so
absolutely sure there is already kubernetes
there's there's already already in recipes
for sodium carbonate he's on a node
but
I kind of I kind of want to do that so one
of the things I like to do now that we got
liverto deliver permission from his working
is I'd like to return tonight I'm going to
have to take another quick break but then
I'm I'm I'm going to I'm going to think
through this and I I'd like we got it we got
ansible already he remained you know
and that's that's really it
you know I see a 75 nothing
we need to put some other stuff. But install
open
SSH server on the virtual machine
yeah this is thing I find interesting this
is not something that I think can be
automated
and I'm concerned about this because
I mean the only way
I think I think the cloud images come with
SSH on them by default you know what I mean
I mean I mean to take stock of the goal
and it's trip to the installer to terraform
but I have a feeling if I use so let's say
let's let's just back up a few steps if I
if I want to provision a bunch of nodes
communities notes and I want knows me to
bbm's
I can run terraform up against a recipe or
whatever
was even called I can remember but
and and I can use the cloud image
and the clown image will come with SSH by
the fault I mean we know we know that the
other reason I want to stop right now
because I've been working with the Linux
Mint one just to see if it worked but I want
to be able to do this with either the a
bunch of the red hat server at this point
I'm thinking about using redhead servers
just cuz I mean we talked a lot about it and
I kind of feel like I'm going to get
and so we bring up me I don't even know how
I would do a rats or do we do not send it
with
do we have a set of us anyway I'm getting
out of myself
I want to come back to automating the
creation of the servers with SSH installed
so that works
as now a stranger rhel did they believe that
the rest of us back right
LeBron said he was back they got rid of it
and then he brought it back
Aurora is too but I think what is the
closest thing to read Enterprise Linux that
anybody could install in their own from
it's all right action and it did to yeah
they got rid of it
it was big news about that and then they
brought it back somehow I don't know how the
rebranding of people react very badly is
that what happened haha so
okay so if I'm going to create a non-profit
environment that's most likely to parallel
the type of environment that I would be
managing on-prem for statistical a probable
Enterprise
I would be setting up a bunch of red hat
Enterprise Linux server probably be doing
such a mess and I don't know but I assume
the sensuous standard server image comes
with s sh would make no sense but didn't
given the fact that they also do ansible and
then I probably don't need to do anything
else I have a feeling that I can write a
terraformed whatever map or whatever and I
can create I can run it and get you know
five actual vm's using terraform and then
you can figure those
I'd like rockin on the Lennox
araki in Alma I thought about this William I
don't want to be too much on the edge there
I probably would like to experiment with
that stuff but I want my base cluster to be
as close to the most probable on Frank
Loesser I would encounter and right now
that's right then and I I just made that
decision today which is different than how I
was thinking about it when I was going to
tear from before when it when we before we
left when we went with a liberty provider
was just have a lot of support I I kind of
we hit all those permissions problems with
you since gotten past and I'm inclined to
use the unpopular Levert provider for
terraform rather than create
a a separate VM as a client for terraforming
then use my whole system as in the server to
be provisioned and cut up which is the way
to do it up time I've been up for 5 hours 30
minutes
so so I think I think I've got that done
so what I'm trying to say is I'm going to
put ansible the bed for bit I got it to work
I know how to use it pretty basic stuff and
writing writing the Play Books is just a
matter of knowing what the yellow
configuration files and say what you want to
install and I do want to do that but but but
I'm kind of stressing out because tomorrow
you go back to work and I really really
really need a VM that I can beat the shit
out of me so that I can test my for my
persistence volume Monitor and I don't have
that yet so I need to set that up and that's
actually my top priority so you do that I'm
going to put out the terraformed I don't
mind taking it a rabbit hole to try to
reform again and it comes down to it by the
end of the night I was just provision 3 vm's
by hand using give me what delivered they
have a diversion
you get Rachel for free
did you ever do a version you need to
register I probably do that
but yeah I mean this is cool and all that
this is is not what I want this is not for
that the endgame right I do like it though
I'll keep it around
Sand Key
quit set running still
816 installs I don't want I'm just going to
send to us
when it when I actually want to do I
actually think I'm going to kill two birds
I'm going to kill two birds with one stone I
like that saying but they going to probably
end up doing is provisioning
like six nodes six or seven notes
add creating a coronavirus environment using
Cube ATM
and I'm going to set up my own storage class
using an offense and then I'm going to
overwhelm the NFL stores by
over-provisioning over allocating just to
keep my pvc I actually think I can get that
pretty quickly I do everything pretty slowly
but but I think I understand how that would
be good I don't want these kind for that and
that's one of the reasons I was doing this
is I mean I can explain what kind of kind is
not a direct comparison to what I want to do
so I'm going to go ahead and provision local
NFS somehow and then I'm going to over
allocate resources to that I'm afraid some
way tomorrow.
It might seem like Overkill to deploy a full
cabinet is environment just to test
provisioning you know what the PVC
consumption checks but I need to do all of
that anyway so this is this is my way of
going about doing it thanks
so
and I want to do it with her for him I want
to stick with her from the Isabel because of
the primary tools that the world is using
these days even if our company is kind of
behind on that
and it still
Santos 3 made okay yeah
so we went through this
Shish repo ad
no cheese info create
example for associative
all right
why is my fan coming on
maybe texting is a little bit too much
ten 7 to ten years wow
wow that's pretty amazing that's that's
that's the one I want to use it
all right so when I come in this
what oh
chances are and you get burned if you are
eating a snake head off
yeah I can see that happening
all right so we will see this
I go back in the lab terraformed thing and
I'm going to set my status
Sarah still cool learning
and we are headed drop the stream to start
up again